good morning
and welcome
I am councilor Mary McLaren and I'm
chairing uh this meeting today so I
would like to remind you of some
domestic Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use and that you
do not interrupt other speakers
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt meeting you
may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones and
laptops are on silent
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
I would like to remind everyone present
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except whether a
confidential or exempt items
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have consent
it to be informed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
council members of the public and the
Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
so I'd like to welcome the following
people to our meeting
so officers in attendance we've got Mark
ends director for operations Nick
Christo corporate manager for public
realm and Stephen Stroud's strategic
projects and delivery manager
we also have John Robinson corporate
manager of Law and governance
and on my left is Alicia Norman who's
the lead officer for overview and
scrutiny
we also would like to welcome our
external Representatives
we have Grant Tufts Regional engagement
manager for Longview and water Natasha
Kenny head of quality regulation and
enforcement for Monday and water
we also like to welcome Ben Marshall's
senior environmental officer for the
environment agency Alison Parnell area
environment manager from the environment
agency that's difficult to say it's
and on on teams we're joined by
lights welcome Nicholas bertoltz senior
advisor for Natural England via teens
and John Kemp the river Stewart Trust on
teens welcome to all of you to our
meeting
can I move to the agenda please
can we have apologies for absence and
substitutions thank you
thank you chair this morning we have
apologies from councilor scarf Roe
Pearson Jameson Caston and Piper and
substituting this morning we have
councilors Marriott Matheson warboys and
Carrabbas
item two
to receive Declarations of pecuniary and
other registrable or non-registered
registerable interests by members
no
item three
Jos
stroke two three stroke one four to
confirm the minutes of the joint meeting
held on the 21st of August
members do we have any points regarding
the accuracy of the minutes
no
could I have a proposed of police I
counselor Grande and a secondary
councilor Wyman
the lead officer will now conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chairman does that vote is now
in progress
counseling Carter
thank you
councilman Riley
can I take your book verbally please
hello councilor Marriott
hmm
Council Mary I'm quite happy happy to
take your vote burpee
councilor Merrick could I take your vote
verbally because it's not come for on my
screen
to the minutes
so would you like to abstain
thank you
thank you chair so that makes five votes
four and five exemptions that's carried
and it's of the giant meeting on the
21st of August 2023 I've been confirmed
before I continue I am very sorry I did
welcome
welcome the director of planning
sorry about that
I think you snuck in there I didn't see
welcome Tom
to receive so item four to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
how can I received here
item five questions by the public then
received and item six questions by
counselors none received here thank you
right we'll go on to the main item of
our agenda
which is item seven and
[Music]
um
that is Jos
slash
23-15 review on current levels of
untreated sewage discharges to Waters in
labor and mid-suffolk
I would like to invite the
um with no cabinet members I would like
to invite the officers which will be
Mark ends to introduce the reports of
the committee
foreign
good morning everybody
um concerns over River quality and
sewage discharge events have been
repeatedly raised by our councilors in
our communities who are worried about
the impacts on both our natural
environment and Public Health
in November 2022 both councils debated
motions on this topic
as a result of this the councils asked
the chair of the scrutiny committee to
invite senior officers of Anglia water
plus representatives from the
environment agency in Natural England to
attend a meeting to answer questions on
the current levels of sewage discharge
officers have provided an information
bulletin for this meeting which sets out
the stakeholders responsibilities the
background and the local context to this
problem
officers do not make any recommendations
to RNs members in respect of river
quality also is discharge into rivers
members have been asked to note the
information contained within the
bulletin when considering questioning of
attendees and of course their own
research and experience in this area
I understand our external invitees we'll
all now introduce their positions on
this matter and then members will be
able to ask their questions
thank you Matt yes I would like like to
invite the external companies in
attendance to make their introductions
thank you very much
thank you chair uh yeah good morning
everybody my name is Grant Tufts
Regional engagement manager from England
water
um we're here today to answer questions
but also we've got a small deck of
slides you might thought we'd run
through beforehand just give some
context a bit more about angling water
and um
later but we're uh we're here to answer
any further ones so do you want to shoot
yourself Tash
good morning everyone
wanted of quality regulation and
enforcement here at anglian water and
I'll be helping Grant with the
presentation today
okay so yeah if you look at the screen
we'll go through some slides
um just a bit of background on hanging
water just for some context of those who
don't know with the biggest water
company by geographical era in England
covering all of East Anglia bits of
linkage here across to west of of
Cambridge and Beyond into parts of
buckinghamshire and Oxfordshire we've
got a big low-lying flat region which
brings certain challenges uh to us as a
good organization
um I mean 5 000 people in Langley and
water serving seven million customers we
do have a lot of a lot of say like those
climate challenges particularly the low
rainfall Point
um and also one of the fastest growing
regions in the ukr Beyond London a lot
of houses being proposed uh stop and
starting as you might have heard
recently but it's back on the agenda and
also we manage lots and lots of assets
particularly sewers 70 76 000 kilometers
of sewers about 38 000 kilometers of
water mains as well so we're a big big
company but we're committed to
protecting the environment and looking
after the people that we serve very well
um
just a brief picture on our strategy
just to explain as what sort of company
we are four key goals angry more to put
out in 2020 2025 our current five-year
business plan about making our lives
better for our customers to deliver our
plan on behalf of those customers along
those priorities and create a
sustainable future for the region so
something really dear to our heart in
fact we changed our articles Association
about four or five years ago within our
companies to shareholders and our owners
to become more Purpose Driven as an
organization so you can read a lot more
about that on a website but really proud
of that the first utility to do that and
we stand by the environmental and social
decisions in all of our operations
um so you know it is is what our belief
is
um along our long-term strategy you can
imagine the water companies are here for
the long term and we have a long-term
Ambitions to help the environment as
well things like being Net Zero
improving the ecological quality of the
of the catch-ups we look after making
the east of England resilience flooding
and drought which is something we're
very mindful of given the climate
impacts and also looking at sustainable
growth we again we're very supportive of
growth if it's done the right way and
again working with all sorts of Partners
including our colleagues today
environment agency and others to make
sure that any development is a
sustainable development for the region
um one of the things obviously we're
here to talk about today is rivers and
the River Health and I'm pleased to
announce that we've we've we've had
anniversary recently of our get River
positive initiative which is um shared
with another one of our neighboring
World company seven Trent and we've got
five key commitments of that of that of
that
a pledge to to look after River's
improved Rivers which is basically as
you can see on the right it's ensuring
storm overflows and story stream where
it's Amber abstraction do not harm
Rivers create more opportunities for
everybody to enjoy our Rivers support
others to care for rivers and lots of
partnership working including with local
authorities like yourselves hopefully
enhance our rivers and create new
habitats for wildlife again something
really really Keen to do maybe
reintroducing species and things like
that and also be more open and
transparent about our data we actually
acknowledge has been a bit of black hole
historically in access to data and
something that we're going to go into
later and to ask my colleague I'll
explain a bit more about that but but
this is this is a campaign that's been
embedded now for a year lots of success
stories do please visit the website we
can share the slide deck afterwards with
the committee with links and things to
these websites but it's something yeah
really dear to our hearts I'm really
proud of this this uh this endeavor
um
we moving on to the the current sort of
on Vogue uh Topic in the industry and on
the media we welcome this scrutiny to be
honest you know we always come to these
meetings we've been so on before with
Suffolk County Council and it's very
room earlier this year and me and my
colleagues go around to lots of other
local authorities uh when we're asked to
do and we're very pleased and I to come
and talk to you and
talk about this this really important
subject but just saw some statistics
about setting the scene you know we
invest a lot in in the environment in
fact 811 million pounds in the current
five-year cycle that's going to double
next the next five years from 2025 2030
to almost 1.6 billion pounds we're
predicting on improving the environment
so we actually are committed to do this
um in terms of sort of csos that Natasha
will explain a bit more about later but
just just to give you some statistics
about combined sewer overloads or storm
overflows that we call them they
contribute just four percent of the
reasons why UK rivers are not in good
quality and in east of England that's
only one percent so there's there's lots
of data about this and again we can
explain a bit more about that later but
to some context about our impact on
Rivers is probably isn't as as severe as
maybe you might read or think or assume
from from what you might see in the
media there are lots of other factors
and we're here alongside the environment
HD to help me talk through those as you
see the bullets there agriculture Urban
runoff native species physical active
collection so a good example we did some
surveys recently in a couple of villages
in Cambridge and one in Essex and we
found that 25 of the of the surface
water connections to the properties are
plumbed straight into the sewer Network
so basically that means that we're
treating rain water from from people's
roofs and Gardens into our sewers which
shouldn't really be they should be going
straight into the environment we
shouldn't be treated so things like that
you know facts and figures that we want
to want to share
um I want to go into detail on the
investment but it's safe to say that we
are putting our money where our mouth is
and spending millions of pounds on
trying to prevent storm overflows from
happening and reduce their impact on the
environment
qualities particularly prevalent for us
particularly on our coastal regions but
we're also starting to look at bathing
water quality Inland as well as you
might have heard and the future really
is about having a plan which we've
already delivered to our to defra on
tackling those storm overflows and
improving Rivers also working with
planning colleagues on the automatic
right to connect which is an anomaly of
the planning legislation where any
developer can connect to our assets
without us being statutory policies
we're now lobbying and we've now managed
to get that into the plan for water
that's Therese Kofi submitted uh earlier
this year so hopefully through a
consultation this year water companies
will have that right so pose development
if it means there's going to be
pollution or impact on the environment
so we're pleased to be lobbying on that
equally Banning on Plastics and wet
wipes again that's something that's in
that plan for water that we've been
we've been lobbying hard over the years
because the impacts of wet wipes in
sewers is quite marked and you'll see
some statistics later that explain that
you know blockages are one of our major
causes of pollutions in the environment
so again banning plastic and wet wipes
which basically stop
blotches and sewers overflowing is
another good step
um
just moving on to sort of the
transparency point we do publish lots of
information about our performance and
our storm overflows retrospectively and
we've got a couple of maps um one one is
our get rid of a positive storm overflow
map which is live on our website now
that's got historical data that's been
validated from last year we're working
towards having live data by end of this
year and Tasha will speak about that a
bit in a bit later on we also have an
interactive investment and operational
map called in your area which again
shows
live data of where things are happening
in in our in our region for things that
also investment decisions and schemes
when we were delivering so we are
becoming more and more transparent and
we want to share more information but
there is more of that coming up
so I'll hand over to Natasha to go
through store workflows and I'll hold
the
thing
thanks Grant so I'm just going to talk a
little bit in more
mail about storm overflows what they are
and how they cover this particular
region so
um storm overflows are located on
combined sewers so combined sewer is a
sewer that accepts both sewage and
rainfall surface water into one
catchment and most of these types of
sewers were built from Victorian times
up until the 1960s and 70s and storm
overflows are located on these systems
because when they become inundated with
periods of rainfall or snow melts these
overflow points will release excess
water to the environment to prevent
homes and businesses from flooding
because it's a combined system
these storm overflows are permitted by
the environment agency because they have
very low or no impact on the receiving
Watercourse and the reason why they have
low or no impact is because the majority
of what they release to the water course
is a rainwater and they are discharging
into a river that's receiving a lot of
rain water too so it's a very dilute mix
that ends up in that water in the
environment
we have been installing event duration
monitors on our storm overflows since
2018 so this was a new requirement for
us to install these types of monitors so
we would know exactly we could count up
how often they spill to the environment
we will have a hundred percent of our
storm overflows in the angling region
with event duration monitors in place by
December 2023
so the event duration monitors will tell
us for how long our storm overflows
discharge for and count up how many
times they discharge
these allow us to have a better
visibility of our sewer Network and if
they are not performing as expected for
example if they're performing outside of
rainfall or snow melt conditions we're
able to take action and invest where
necessary
we've currently got about 87 of our
storm overflows with event duration
monitoring in place and as I've said
earlier we'll achieve 100 coverage by
December 2023
data that our edms collect
is sent off to the environment agency on
a regular basis we also send it off to
the rivers trust and we publish it on
our website
we also use the information that these
eventuation monitors produce on a
day-to-day basis
following the activation we will assess
the data to determine if a spill has
occurred
what we are finding is about one-third
of the activations of false Bill events
and that is because as Grant mentioned
earlier
because of external factors can
influence these monitors from Reading
accurately for example when we get a lot
of fat in the sewer or if we get them
flushables that cause blockages we could
end up with these focusable events
because it gives us a false level in the
sewer Network
we are working
with companies who provide these devices
to improve accuracy and use alternative
devices to improve the way in which we
monitor spills
so
we are focusing on continuously
improving accuracy of storm overflow
monitoring and we are also looking to
reduce those to the environment as well
in 2022 our data showed that we had a
reduction of 54 in spills in comparison
to our 2021 return
so we've looked at the average spill per
overflow in baber in 2022 was 9.5 per
storm overflow and in mid-suffolk it was
12.45 per storm overflow
figures show that we are also treating
our Wastewater 99 of the time which
means we hold the flows within our
sewage system 99 of the time so it's
only that extra one percent that is
being discharged to the environment
through these storm overflows
we do have problems in OSS your network
and we do have pollution instance that
happen this is something we don't want
to happen and we do focus on trying to
minimize and eliminate these as much as
we can these event duration monitors
help us to provide more visibility of
what's going on in our catchments and we
had one incident caused by a blockage in
2023 in the mid-suffolk area and that um
in a nun in the Weber area that was
classified as a minor pollution incident
so as I've said we're trying to focus on
reducing storm spills to the environment
and we uh work with the environment
agency on developing a five-year program
which is called our water industry
National environment program
and our five-year program is currently
running between 2020 to 2025 and some of
the figures here on us focusing on
investing to reduce those spills to the
environment includes 56 million pounds
being spent on increasing capacity our
water treatment works 80 million pounds
on installing additional storm tanks 23
million on increasing overflow
monitoring and improving visibility and
2.1 million on improving bathing water
quality
we're increasing our sewer monitors over
and above the event duration monitoring
project by extra 22 000 monitors going
into our sewer Network as Grant says
we're working on our get River positive
commitments
and we are also starting to use more
artificial intelligence and Data Systems
to improve the way in which we use all
of the data that these devices provide
us so that we can be more proactive in
preventing spills when they're operating
outside of their permit conditions so we
can stop pollutions from happening
we've also invested this in this
five-year period on carrying out surveys
on those storm overflows where they may
be harming the environment and where we
are investing in 11 locations across the
anglo-mortar region under the storm
overflow and asset framework
so
we are asked a lot about how do we
eliminate storm overflows operating all
together and that is a huge challenge if
we removed all storm overflows it would
require whole towns and cities to be
replumbed which would be very expensive
and disruptive
so we are focused on reducing harm from
our storm overflows that is our priority
we have got currently uh
1552 storm overflows in the angular
region and 61 of those are in the baber
and mid-suffolk regions
in recent years we've surrendered
permits for over 16 of Arsenal overflows
so they no longer operate
but we also understand that by improving
water quality we need to work in
partnership with the rivers trust
Farmers landowners and highways in order
to jointly work together to reduce storm
overflow harm to rivers and other
reasons why rivers are not achieving
good
status
so we use our eventuation monitoring to
drive
investigations and we will take action
and report to the environment agency if
any of our discharges our pollution our
pollutions and the environment agency
performance assess us and take action
against us if they think that we are not
operating as a responsible sewerage
Undertaker
but we do resolve issues and we take we
make investment where a repair or
replacement is required in our sewer
Network
looking ahead
we will carry on reporting storm
overflows unless Grant says we've got a
map that shows our 2022 assessment data
however we know that customers want to
know information in near real time so we
are releasing a near-time reporting map
of our storm overflow activities in
December 2023 and we're working on that
at the moment
we've submitted a storm overflow
reduction plan to deathra and that is
due to be published very soon so that
will also be released imminently and
we're also submitting our business plan
to off what in October and that will
include a significant increase in
investment to focus on storm overflows
overall it's 11 billion pounds but 1.6
billion of that is about improving
schemes to improve the environment
that's nearly double the size of the
plan that we are delivering in 2020 to
2025.
thank you very much
thank you grant and Natasha now what
we're going to do is go through all the
different agencies that are represented
here before we go to questions so I'd
now like to invite Ben and Allison to
speak on behalf of the environment
agency thank you very much thank you
good mornings Allison Parnell and the
environment manager for Suffolk working
for the environment agency I don't have
a deck of slides but I'm really happy if
we want some additional information
sending through or some material to
follow up but I thought I'd just give
you a little flavor of who we are and
then we'll see how the discussion goes
through your questions when we get to
that point so primarily the environment
agency is the environment regulator
um
we have an ability to protect Rivers but
that's very much focused on the
environment and I think you mentioned
human
ear earlier in that is less of a focus
of the current regulations and our
ability to protect Rivers is really
driven by the regulations we have to
hand but also our available resources in
terms of undo we are given to achieve
those regular games
when it comes to sewage discharges as
you've explained we permit those so the
regular discharges that are occurring
continuously from treated sewage
effluent going into the river would have
conditions that
flow that is being discharged but also
some of the concentrations of pollutants
primarily this will be things like
phosphates when you're looking at
um
paper it showed you some of the
conditional status of the rivers in
terms of the water framework directive
which is actually the water environment
regulations UK
that is one of the primary drivers for
the status of those Rivers being in a in
a less than favorable condition is
phosphate along with dissolved oxygen
and also plant growth in the rivers
plant growth is primarily in rivers
fueled by phosphates the more we can
manage phosphates but there are other
substances we control through those
permits
we're also here to hold the water
company to account and I think they can
attest that we have done and we do and
this year we had one case against you
for a permit breach and in Essex which
resulted in a two and a half million
pound fine so it's encouraging the
courts are taking these matters more
seriously too so we do Whole to account
where we've got serious pollution
um
we also as I think you've explained
kindly is we direct water company
investment we get involved at looking
where we think the environment should
improved to meet the regulations and the
work that can be done and that helps
inform your asset planning working with
Waters to to what that plan should be
shaped like
but protecting the water environment is
actually a really big Challenge and one
that we all play a part in so whilst you
know we do a lot of work in Partnership
and part of the ethos of the water
environment regulations is to work in
Partnership and we work in partnership
with anglo-water they have the means um
to come in and help bring about
improvements to the environment all
public bodies have a duty to regard of
regard to the River Basin plan and the
River Basin plan is the thing that is
the document that sets out the
objectives and what we need to do to
achieve better status in our Rivers
across baber and mid-suffolk
so there's plenty we can be doing
together so it'd be helpful to perhaps
have some discussions around how we can
work together more to
the local environment
there's many things from the
misconnections you mentioned invasive
species planning is a really big driver
even just your own assets looking at
water usage have you got those
misconnections are yours any sewage
treatment works that you might own so is
treatment plants connected to any
properties you have operating properly
things that could like seem small but
collectively can really help
um and then I think finally I'd just say
I suppose climate change is bringing an
increasing challenge so we're getting
differing weather
and that weather is becoming more
unpredictable and those volumes of water
are becoming more intense which brings
the challenges back to those storm
overflows there's a lot we need to be
doing about how
grateful to prevent all of that rain
water going into the sewage systems and
overwhelming our existing technical
abilities to treat that sewage and again
that's I think something we can come
together and then finally you know it
isn't just sewage that's impacting the
rivers land use particularly agriculture
when you look um if you look at the
proportional impacts between
the water companies and agriculture
agricultures actually has a slightly
bigger impact on the quality of the
environment and again heavy rainfall
agricultural practices will run off all
um
exasperate the condition and the health
of our Rivers
so I just give you a little bit of
flavor of what we're about and see where
the discussion takes us
thank you
thank you Alison Ben are you going to
no okay uh Mandy can we go to our
visitors who are on teams thank you
can I invite Nicholas to do his
presentation on Natural England thank
you Nicholas
thank you um can we just do a quick
check can you still can you hear me
sufficiently yeah we can
yeah so hello everybody I'm Nick Bertolt
I'm has introduced at freshwater senior
advisor for Natural England in the base
of the Norfolk and Southern team
um I'll give a very I don't have any
slides or presentations
um but I'll give a quick run through of
where and how our Natural England is
working within the sort of water
environment and then yes like Allison
said see where the discussions and
questions take us from there that's okay
um so I just if I may just start sort of
from a slightly higher level in this
sort of ecological level and
the sort of very simply wetlands have
what could be sort of almost distilled
down to something of a Trilogy of
factors that you know rivers and other
Wetlands that need to be right for them
to thrive and be resilient
for both the environment and people and
how people use that environment so that
sort of water quality water supply and
then the habitat condition as well which
is sort of a management the extent and
how people use it so our approach is
looking at all of those factors through
all of the tools we can deliver to get
that overall Improvement in the water
environment so
um of sort of talk and think probably
more widely than just csos
for that so Natural England if I start
with the sort of top and zoom into
slightly more detail we're there working
to sort of support the delivery of the
government's 25-year environment plan
and a plan for water and meeting those
sort of government
Ambitions and then Natural England have
an action plan that supports that shows
how Natural England are going to do that
um with a series of clip of goals for
delivery throughout the sort of the year
um
this year natural engine is sort of
looking to sort of maximize what's the
impact of sort of some of the new tools
that have come in through the
environment actually that can deliver
nature recovery local nature recovery
strategies biodiversity net gain for
example
um and one of the other
priorities within there that's already
been mentioned previously is sort of
collaborating both across government
regulators and with Partners to sort of
develop solutions to address these
environmental pressures
um
and one of those aspects that's relevant
to today is looking at these strategic
water plans so that water industry
National environment program that has
already been mentioned and other water
company plans and also we advise the
environment agency on permits where they
particularly affect protected sites
now
having mentioned that again Allison
mentioned that the sort of the
regulatory framework within which the
environment agency predominantly
operates Natural England has a similar
as a regulatory framework similarly
a lot of our work is driven by the
need to restore and protect protected
sites so that site's a special
scientific interest triple sis special
areas of conservation sacs and then
ramsars and other other designated
protected sites
so
our sort of main focus like often can be
slightly more narrowed down onto those
protected sites rather than the wider
River Network which sits more within the
environment agency's regulatory remit
um
and then I'll just touch on some of the
sort of the mechanisms that we use to
help restore the environment so
protected sites looking at the majority
of the protected sites when the local
the two local authorities areas
um are woodlands in number which are
sort of sitting on the sort of Suffolk
clay so they're more directly rainwater
Fed so not so impacted by the surface
water issues perhaps plenty of issues of
their own climate change invasive
species new diseases
then looking at others just to the north
of the area the red grave and lopham
group of wetlands sites are very very
special and really important and
that sort of catchment and their
groundwater recharge zones are within
the local authorities areas so there is
an issue thinking about
those in the way
water is managed within the local Visa
this area but also there are two
significant designated estuaries the
Orwell and the star estuaries
um are designated as protected sites and
the catchments for both of those and
part of the Estuary sit within these
mid-sufficient babies areas and also
similarly very important Estuary the
debun is outside of these local
authorities but the very top of its
catchment sits within your area as well
and for those protected sites yeah there
are many pressures on them Coastal
squeeze related to climate change which
is when sea levels rise and then the
sort of fringes of the habitat have got
nowhere to go up against the sort of Bud
walls and flood defenses
um but also nutrient issues are becoming
more apparent there and as being said
before nutrient issues on these sort of
sites is yes it's phosphates but it's
also very heavily driven particularly by
nitrates which the main sources of that
are agriculture land use runoff and how
water is sort of managed within the wide
attachment
as well
now
they're within the
um 25 year environment plan there is a
target for 75 of all these protected
sites to be in what we call favorable
condition
um by 2042
um
and then with some interim targets that
have been put in place in the
environment Improvement plan
um that by 2028
um we need to have up-to-date condition
assessments and mechanisms in place to
address the issues that these protected
sites are facing
and
that point about up-to-date condition
assessments is quite important because
some of our sort of records and data for
these sites are quite out of date but
there is a big program going on to work
through all the protected sites in our
area and get an up-to-date understanding
of the condition of them all and like I
said then identify the features identify
the mechanisms by which we can
prove the condition of those sites
and some of those mechanisms which I'll
touch on now very quickly
um
have been said Natural England
work with water companies like anglian
water and then within and in conjunction
with the environment agency to feed into
the environment program that we've
mentioned Natural England advised the
environment agency on the River Basin
management plans which have already been
mentioned
um
and also we advise the environment
agency on consultations for permits and
plans which
potentially affect could affect
protected sites
um
they're addressing some of these wider
issues we've got various tools that
Natural England use for that there is
catchment sensitive farming which is
advisors go out and colleagues with mine
go out and
advise Farmers on good practice support
agri-environment applications to address
water issues and that can be from
managing runoff from yards and buildings
to fields and buffers and soil quality
what sort of structure soil management
to improve in what is double improve
water quality
um
they more widely agri-environment
schemes with a lot of agri-environment
schemes in your area a lot of those are
being delivered for The Wider
environment also there's a lot of
um
options and actions within those
agreements to address water quality
issues particularly things like runoff
and so that buffer strips around field
edges and
alongside sort of rivers and things like
this to avoid sort of sediment and
nutrients or reduce the sediment and
nutrients that does enter the waterways
that ultimately feed into the protected
sites but also the wider environment
and then I'll just finish off by just
sort of touching on and
the developing plans under local nature
recovery strategies and colleagues of
mine are working with the Suffolk County
councils and Norfolk County Council to
develop their local nature recovery
strategies
and I understand that
the county councils are very keen for
district authorities who like Natural
England within the local nature recovery
strategy sort of legislation are what's
called supporting authorities so you
have a sort of a a role within the
legislation similarly to Natural England
to advise on those local nature recovery
strategies and the actions and the
mechanisms that can be put in place
through through those
which yeah I think hopefully will be
very well aligned within the room as a
whole to sort of start looking at
um
improving you taking actions to improve
water quality buffer strips enhancing
River corridors
better flood management natural flood
Management nature-based Solutions where
possible
so yeah
and then finally just sort of touch on
also advise on sort of planning
applications and local plans and
colleagues of mine at the moment have
been advising on your local local plan
and providing some specific sort of
advice to consider water quality and
water supply as well as other
environmental issues within that so
yeah I think we'll I'll sort of pause
there but we've got a range of tools
that we use and
I think along with everybody we
recognize there is
real priority for the environment in
this area
we need to do more there are still lots
of issues to be addressed um but we're
very much
in the space of endeavoring to address
those environmental issues that we face
and again just one final point I think
throughout most of natural England's
plans and policies in Partnership is a
key theme so
which has already been mentioned before
so that's because we can't you know do
it all on our own in a silo as a
regulator
thank you
thank you Nicholas come on now invite
John to speak on behalf of the uh River
Stewart trust thank you John
good morning I hope you can hear me
my name is John Kemp and I represent the
river store trust which is making a
joint application together with Sudbury
Town Council for basing water status for
that stretch of the river stir between
The Granary cut and cornard lock that is
the distance of about three quarters of
a mile and importantly includes Friars
Meadow which is one of the main
recreational areas of Sudbury that is a
widely used stretch of river used by
swimmers canoes rowers paddle boarders
and of course the river store trusts own
electric passenger launches
we are now at a very Advanced stage in
this application which has to be with
defra during October Texas would compel
the environment agency to test the water
every week during the bathing season
that's from mid-may to the end of
September publish the results
this of course we've also put some
pressure on anyone who might be polluted
in the water to stop doing so there are
very few of these uh designated bathing
areas on proper Rivers there are several
hundred at Seaside towns and in
estuaries you can count the number of
proper rivers on the fingers of one hand
we intend to be one of them
although deathra
unhelpfully changed the rules halfway
through the season we have been able to
match their requirements in terms of
numbers of swimmers and local facilities
and we have undertaken an extensive
range of consultations
so our application is supported by all
the main river users the Rowing Club
which has an international reputation
the scouts the Canoe Club the Anglers
and importantly the common lands charity
which manages much of the land bordering
and above this section of the river we
are also very pleased to have the the
full support of anglium water who have
been very helpful in very encouraging we
have also undertaken an extensive
consultation with the public via public
meetings and a consultation stroke
petition form which has now been
completed by at least 1600 people
now we come to my main reason for
speaking to you today uh Madam chairman
there is one thing we are sure of and
it's something I hope that this meeting
will remedy and that is the support of
baber District Council who of course
owns Friars Meadow I did write to your
Council back in January this year and I
received a reply from your chief
executive which went thus in principle
baber District Council would support the
river store trusts application to obtain
designated basing water status however
we are aware that improving water
quality in rivers is a complicated issue
in which there are already several
stakeholders and groups we are actively
involved with
I think you will agree that he's not
quite the wholehearted support that I'm
looking for thank you madam chairman
feel the the emotion in that and thank
you very much for that contribution
we now come to
um
members asking questions we've heard a
lot of information and I know the
committee are all anxious to ask their
questions and so as a change because it
is such a
um important subject to to members we're
going to go with a more orderly way of
questions and I'm going to go uh
from counselor to counselor because
everybody said they had questions to ask
councilor Mathison can I start with you
thank you very much
thank you chair
I feel yeah spot for choice where to
begin really
um
well
perhaps if I could ask
um
about this this the the storm spills
what what I think is is striking and not
um
not acceptable to the public really is
that
um
there are still so many of these spills
um but we're the driest region in the
country and
um
so
if these spills are supposed to only
occur
after heavy rain and we don't have that
much Heavy Rain occasionally we do but
not that often
um I just wonder
can you actually
tell us whether as I read nationally has
it's happening sometimes where there are
storm spills when we haven't had any
rain at all for the last 48 hours you
know I mean how can that actually happen
so one of the biggest challenges
the finding with our EDM program is that
um is the fact that we get external
factors that can influence when they
activate
and these can be caused by
um that's getting into the sewer or
blockages and they give an artificially
high level and part of the challenges
we're facing at the moment is a lot of
the activations that are reported in the
papers are not true spill events we do
provide information to journalists when
they ask for the information and we
actually do provide them with supporting
information to to state actually that
we're having problems with Katie because
of interference from external factors so
we're finding about a third of the
activations are false Bill events so
that is influencing our data set but we
are focused on driving improvements to
make sure that those don't occur
anything that's happening outside of a
rainfall event is
um is not a storm overflow and we have a
requirement to report that to the
environment agency as a pollution and
that we do follow those procedures I
know there's a lot of data out there at
the moment that looks like there's a lot
of storm spills happening in dry weather
anything that happens in dry weather is
reported to the environment agency and
there are very low numbers of that of
that that happening but we do know we've
got a data accuracy issue that we're
focused on improving as well
we're working very closely with the EA
we do share some of the challenges we
face but I think one of the things that
would really help us to improve
the situation is reducing the amount of
the amount of rubbish that people flush
down their sewer systems because
actually it does cause us a huge amount
of problem with data accuracy on Storms
films
councilor Mathison do you have another
question
so okay
yes thank you chair
um I think my questions were
was it tough the regional engagement
officer but I may be wrong
it comes from uh work on a planning
committee really some time ago
we we actually call on a grumpy emotion
for a chicken
firm which
had to in order to receive planning
permission had to show that it was at
the capacity to harvest sufficient
rainwater to deal with its leaves so it
put no stress on the existing Water
Services which it subsequently has
um which I think is was a reasonable
decision on the part of the planning
committee
um
again I think it's part of the reason
why you're here today we had another
planning committee meeting which dealt
with two developments of about 250
houses in Stow Market the first one was
was for detailed planning permission
which already had outline planning
permission
and
only water responded that they had
sufficient capacity to deal with the
outflows from this development
the second request for plan input was
request for outline plan information
and Anglia water
said that insufficient capacity to deal
with the sewage
now that put the planning committee in
my opinion
in a very difficult situation we had us
we could not refuse planning permission
because Angley water had insufficient
capacity
and my understanding neither do you
have
the ability to refuse to connect to that
development
um
250 houses produces about 37 and a half
million Elite you of water which what
goes in must come out
um now my question I think it's
more of a request really are you able
and will you give our planning officers
sufficient detail when we are get
deciding these planning decisions in
order to
bring out into the open in the interests
of transparency the costs and
consequences of these developments in
terms of dealing with the water we get a
response from Anglia Waters we get a um
sorry Suffolk highways we get responses
from
health and education that we need that
information so that we are aware and the
public is aware of the consequences of
those developments on our water supplies
and our discharges
thank you
yeah thank you for the question
um you've obviously I touched it earlier
but you raised a really important point
about our role in planning and as you
should understand we're not statue
Consultants or planning applications so
by law we can't comment necessarily on
um
in enough with enough Force to stop a
development proceeding if that's the
local planning authority to to install
uh to implement conditions if we think
there needs to be conditions to a
development but but there is this
automatic right to connect as you said
so as I said we are Lobby we're lobbied
for that and that is a change in the law
that hopefully will come about through
the plan for water which has been
submitted to death for this this year
um with regard to those particular cases
I also don't know those in detail but
our planning of our planning team in
England water do scrutinize developments
of that size yeah we literally troll
through planning portals and trying to
find them and engage with the local
planning Authority and developers to
making to ensure that what is being
proposed isn't going to add detriment to
the environment
um in terms of supplying water you know
again we've got a statue obligation to
supply fresh water to domestic
properties but not to businesses to pick
up your first point about the chicken
farm which I know I think quite a lot of
media coverage so we have to focus a lot
on supplying water for domestic use
above that for industry and business
which again is a an anomaly in the
regulations
um but that's what it is but we do again
work with those businesses and those of
those Industries to try and find ways to
save water become more efficient or
self-sufficient in terms of wood storage
that sort of thing because we as I said
we want to develop and grow the region
as much as anybody else does but in a
sustainable way so but that's your your
particular point about adding comments
and and and conditions when our teams do
do that but ultimately with the
information we provide could only be
um applicable to that particular
development and what we're all what
we're not unable to do in the in the law
is to talk about things that are
existing issues that that developer
hasn't got them hasn't got a part to
play in so we all we could do is come
out on that particular
um development
proposal if there are existing flooding
issues or other issues that can't be
part of that consultation feedback or
not that part of that feedback we give
to the planning Authority so it's up to
the planning authority to bring all that
information together to make a decision
and and accept or not the the conditions
that we think we might need to you might
need to put on so it's a complicated
subject but hopefully it will become
clearer as we become statutory
consequent
to say in these things
thank you I think I think that's it I
think
I think my request is for more
information basically so are we going to
get that yeah well yeah I think our our
teams will provide the information that
they they can try not to say sort of
where we we're not allowed to talk about
existing issues in a catchment or a
development location if there are if
there are already concerns over water
quality or flood risk then the developer
hasn't yeah hasn't got an obligation to
fix any of those if if they are
proceeding with their own development
but we would we would comment on
individual applications and what that
would mean for that catchment would it
make it worse would it make it better
that sort of so yeah our teams would do
that so we I can I can we can follow up
later if you need if we need to in that
particular development I can talk to our
pre-development team and get some
information if we need more
bye
just from the environment agency and
um just wanted to really make points I
think it points very good the the
pressure of development and growth both
on
the ability to treat so the the capacity
of sewage works with increasing
development is a challenge so we put on
standards on permits and the water
company will increasingly find it
difficult to meet those standards as the
pressure on the sewage Works increases
through development and they are obliged
if those houses are there they have to
connect them so we are getting to a
point and I think you're quite astutely
bringing that out where the capacity and
the scale of growth the other point you
also raised around the chicken farm is
that we're also at a point where our
availability to abstract water from the
environment is now very limited and
we've got challenges and issues across
East Anglia where we because we also
regulate the abstraction of water so
Essington Suffolk water provide drinking
water and much of mid-suffolk
so we would regulate their abstractions
to protect the environment whether
that's ground Waters or rivers or we
have sort of minimum flows that the
environment would need and we're at the
point already where you know we're
having to work really hard with the
water companies to balance the need for
fresh water to Industry and people to
the environment and we've got some
difficult conversations currently
happening around Cambridge just on that
matter and we've got some challenges
that I'm sure Natural England could talk
about around Wetland habitats in Norfolk
and impacting actually having to cause
reductions to abstraction volumes that
are currently in place to protect
environments so I think your comments
are very
well placed and I think you know that
planning challenge is quite significant
you know we we need the housing we need
the growth but the environment in this
part of the world it you know is already
on a fine line so
I just wanted to say thank you for those
comments
not for the minute
I'm very aware of our two other agencies
that are on teams
can we just ask them if they want to
Nicholas and John do you want to make
any comments on those that those
questions
nothing from me Madam chairman
Nicholas nothing from me at this point
[Music]
yeah do you want to take our thousand
points around sort of the more details
of the
um
abstraction issues for the environment I
can't do but I would imagine this is
probably not quite the right forum for
going into the detail of that but I'm
happy to have a conversation if need be
so late today
I don't I don't want you to feel
excluded from the meeting
oh it's come on now
um really a question for Allison in the
environment agency
um you mentioned um
concentrations of pollutants and also
plant growth and I live in in Brantford
by the river river gipping and sort of
on my normal walk I I appreciate that
plants grow a lot more in the summertime
but it is really sort of chocolate with
with plant growth at the moment so much
so you sort of Wonder can these sort of
get more hands the Coots Etc can they
can they actually get through and there
was somebody the other day on a
um we call it a paddle board and um I
was just thinking it's clear here but
what would it be like a bit further on
so is there actually a sort of program
for clearing that plant growth
okay yeah I can respond sorry so
um
we for flood
purposes for prevention purposes we do
want to take some levels of weed cutting
through our flood flood sort of
functions
however you know we only do that where
we can see there's a genuine benefit to
property or business that
we're cutting May assist one of the
challenges we have in our Rivers is flow
so with drier hotter Summers our river
flows are decreasing I talked about the
phosphates
so in a river we've got too much coming
in in terms of nutrients and phosphates
and the plants love it so one of the
challenges we have is we have warm water
slow flowing
lots of nutrient and the plants are very
happy so our Rivers a lot of our Rivers
um
creasingly becoming quite choked with
plant growth and it is not something
that we are funded to go in and do but
what we will do we are doing is we work
with natural England we have Farm
inspections we advise Farmers to about
how they might manage their land
companies have permits that bring in
phosphate reduction and I think you've
got
probably about 10 or 11 schemes
currently from phosphate reduction
across the patch and some of those will
be on the Gippy it's all of those
actions to actually get to the root
cause of why we've got those plants
there in the first place we will take
some mitigation if we feel that
dissolved oxygen because
very hot as Ben knows he spends many an
hour responding to fish the fish will
start to struggle because the plants
obviously is it at night when you get
the oxygen levels depleted so we do we
do get involved and it does cause
impacts through reduction oxygen which
then impacts on on the fish and we will
get involved then whether that's a
rating a river sometimes we'll open up
at sluice if we think that might just
help with a little bit of flow to to do
that but much of that is mitigation we
need to get to that root cause that
we're not putting the wrong things down
can you investigate what's happening to
the fish then but only that we know
that's dissolved oxygen caused by the
plant growth yes yes and so what we have
to do is prevent the plant growth by
getting back to that nutrient inputs so
we
you know we put angling water investing
through their the program where we've
said we would want to see phosphate
reduction that is happening I don't know
whether you put them all in place yet
but it's happening at the moment through
the current asset planning process and
we're working with landowners to reduce
that neutral input well and we manage
the um abstractions from the river
within what within our regulatory
ability to make sure there is flow down
the river
um I just wanted to say something else
about um bathing water status I mean
it's um I think admirable that sudbria
are working on this but um there are
lots of other small areas that of rivers
where people do bathe and I suppose that
they don't stand any chance of getting
bathing water status because it's not on
a large enough scale but I I am sort of
concerned and there's an area in
Brantford where people you know in warm
weather they regularly jump off the
bridge they regularly bathe they're
somewhere else in blakenham
um and heard recently of a somewhere
near sprouton where there were concerns
about pollution in the river and you
wonder how much of that has sort of
come further down
yes so our regulations are primarily
focused at protecting the environment
not anyone you're talking about
so I'm assuming
served with pathogens things yeah so
um
bathing water you know designation and
the rules around what makes a bathing
water sits with the secretary of state
and defra
when they are designated obviously will
go in and monitor those
rivers are really challenging
it was challenging enough at the sea and
I'll leave the water company to talk
about investment but in salt water in
sunlight you've got large dilutions lots
of sun quite a hostile environment and
those pathogens naturally Decay but
there's been vast investments in
ultraviolet treatment on their at the
end of pipe to improve baby water
surround the coast when you get to a
river it's not just the sewage it is the
land runoff you and you know if you go
through a park it can even be dog muck
that can cause a challenge so in
attachment you have a much more complex
series of inputs you don't have the same
level of dilution you don't have that
same hostile salt water environment so I
think improving
for you know in terms of human health
and pathogens the river
[Music]
is not something the regulations
currently look at and I think that the
the complexity of a catchment will
involve a lot of people including
yourselves in terms of planning
misconnection you know lamb juice coming
together to bring about those
improvements they are they will be
particularly challenging and does being
designated doesn't necessarily mean it
will be it is not connected to the
quality what what the designation will
do is help Focus the ability for the
water company to drive Investments but
also perhaps Target
work that's carried out in those
catchments to trying to prove it so any
bathing water on any River will start to
bring some improvements for the
catchment
yeah I've just got one more comment
about the catchment sensitive farming
and and it's very good that all these
different agencies are working together
to improve farming practices
um but just a quick suggestion I think
it would be for us councilors going out
and there might be a particularly in
Mid-South there are quite a lot of farms
we come into contact it I would really
like to have a little training session
on that just to learn a few Basics about
it to be able to discuss with Farmers
when we meet them
that would be natural England for catch
sensitive farming but I'm happy to just
respond on you know
that educational piece we do work with
the rivers trust and there are
Partnerships looking at
um working with Farmers I'm sure
there'll be links there in terms of
helping you understand the actions and
the advice and guidance yeah
yeah
but if I may just
add to that aren't you
yes
thank you yeah sorry
um yeah um yes
um if you would like to get in touch
with me after this meeting
um sort of what you'd like to see um we
can hear certainly I can talk to Captain
sensitive farming colleagues and we can
come up with a plan of something that
would be useful for you but yeah very
much welcome that sort of yeah getting
the message out there through all needs
and a nice consistent message
um it's really helpful thank you
can I just
try to start so Alison just mentioned
about
um phosphorus schemes so to reduce
phosphorus into the um catchments we do
currently have phosphorus schemes that
are going to be delivered
um by 2025 so we have one at Hadley
which is reducing the phosphorus
standard to one milligram per liter
we've also got one at Norton and one at
elmswell
so there are three schemes there there's
one at debenham
um as well so we've got four schemes in
total that need to be delivered by 2025
so that um will reduce the phosphorus
going into the Watercourse and prevents
that plant growth from happening
good thank you
thank you councilor Marriott councilor
grunden
thank you madam chairman it may be that
you've just answered my question
actually
um I'm a member for Hadley South
and a lot of the year in Hadley and it
happens every year
went in the future
we have green
covering the whole of the river
and it seems to me but just from a
resident observing that we seem to have
less wildlife
in in and around the river
if that's not correct but that's what it
appears to be
can you comment on that or have you
already answered that with your answer
just now
so yeah so I can I took and talk about
it from an angry water perspective so
yes um one of the schemes that we are
delivering is the um phosphorus scheme
at Hadley water recycling center so that
will be discharging into that local area
um I don't have my map with me so I'm
not sure what's Upstream of the Rhythm
whether we've got further schemes it's
possible but I cannot take that away as
an action and find out but Hadley yes we
are the phosphorus standard for the
discharge to the environment that it's
being tightened to one milligrams per
liter and that is to improve the
geological sorry the good ecological
status of the Watercourse it will be
higher phosphorus levels will be
encouraging that plant growth to happen
so this tighter stuff
very rude um yeah it's called lemon or
it's duckweed I think it's what you're
thinking about tiny little platelet
leaves yeah that has been increasingly
over the last few hot dries
very little rainfall for about three
years now very abnormal and we've we've
noticed that a lot of our Rivers it's
primarily also driven by sort of lower
the slower flows with those hot dry
Summers if you think of our Rivers they
were very artificially created with
Mills they're beautiful we've got some
amazing Heritage and history or what it
fundamentally is doing to our Rivers
which naturally would be really small is
making a series of pondered struck you
know and lemner is primarily a pond or a
lake type plant it likes slow flows it
will
the nutrients
and yes you're right it does have that
sort of smothering and we are we do get
very concerned about it and sometimes
we'll bring an aerator in to break that
up if we and we do on some Rivers keep
an eye on that dissolved oxygen so it's
very important bit for us is that we get
any reports on them as public if they
see fish in distress or anything
associated with those sort of lemon
covers because we will respond and take
a look at your cells that we as a child
should get if if you we won't come and
remove the lemonade but if you see fish
that are struggling because of the
respond to support support that so what
we do do at the uh very bottom of this
store the last couple of years we've
been putting a device in which
constantly measures the dissolved oxygen
sends it
a website
you can we can track on a graph what the
dissolved oxygen levels are doing
and when they drop down to sort of less
than 20 we would then open the sluice
gate if we can to flush that limiter out
from the bottom because it ends up with
a pool of effectively stagnant water
we've had some pretty serious fish kills
in the last few years so
by putting these monitors in every
summer we keep an eye on it before
something happens
we were able to deal with it
and I think you know to me this is very
reflective of where I think your
colleagues you know counselor said we're
in a very dry part of the world we are
an exceptionally dry part of the world
with high demands or The Limited water
we've got and I think we're just
starting to really feel that with our
Rivers now in the we manage the
abstraction and we're doing everything
we can to make sure we're protecting the
environment but we're just hitting I
think some of those tension points now
in terms of what's available for growth
and people and what's needed for the
environment and
stations
that's it for now
yeah absolutely councilor Riley
thank you madam chairman uh I've got two
very simple questions actually the first
one is e is the easy one of course
um your slides here you have a budget of
811 million pounds for 20 to 20 25. how
much would that budget have we spent so
far
a good question I don't know to be
honest yeah I mean I think I think we've
got about another
120 odd million next year to spend but
we'll find out we can find out for you I
don't know the details but yeah when we
find out can you uh feed in so it's
emailed to all the members uh because
fine words here but I don't know
parsnips now then this is lovely course
looking at this wonderful map which is
on page three we'll page 15.
um I look at the flows into Plywood And
scrotum and the flows everywhere else
and there's an awful lot of poor
uh statuses and there's an awful lot of
moderate spaces so it was very little
there's good
and so the question is
when can I perish my ward expect us to
go from poor to moderate to good
so the regulations put a deadline of
2027 I think that is dependent on
investment by many people it's you know
that is something we all have to
contribute in terms of a partnership the
reasons there's some things that already
are good and there's some
already
um
so some of the invertebrates like the
small bugs that we measure with the
water regulations water framework
directive it's like there's a number of
things that are monitored
and
if any one of those is not good we say
the whole stretch isn't good so it's
like one hour all out so it doesn't mean
everything's wrong with the river but it
can it can certain things the main
reasons that we're very orange and
yellow is phosphate which we've had
quite a lot of conversation around and
we've talked about the actions and the
investment
phosphate is quite pernicious it doesn't
go anywhere it's some
attached to sediment so it sort of it
just keeps cycling through the
environment so we're looking at the
water company to strip it out when it
goes to the sewage works we also need to
look at what's put on the land
by farming because it's a fertilizer
that they use so there's a lot of advice
and guidance to Farmers to manage what
they're putting on the land but it's
also in the things we eat it's in the
things we're flushing down the toilets
are looking at the products there's been
reductions in the phosphate
concentration of some of the products we
buy if you look at your detergent
they're often full of phosphate over
time if you look back to the 80s to
where we are now the phosphate levels
have closed so there's but the phosphate
doesn't go anywhere it would stick to
the sediment and it will slowly so even
if we cut everything off now
phosphate will still be attached to the
river sediment and when you get flows it
will get resuspended and it takes a long
time for phosphate levels to drop so I
don't fully expect phosphate to be under
control by 2027 I'm just being really
honest with you the other drivers that
are making these Amber and yellow is
dissolved oxygen which we've said is
linked to River flow and linked to
plants
through carbon dioxide and oxygen and
then you've also got the fact that there
is a lot of plants which are being
driven by the nutrients going in so
they're the things if you heard when
we're talking we're focusing on working
on and working with Partners working
with other land use working with
industry to try and minimize that
nutrient input to drive a change in
color
so is that case of
not this year not next year but sometime
possibly never
so it's a case of we're doing everything
we can with the resources and
drive those changes
well phosphate is a challenge
we've just employed it's around a dozen
agricultural regulation offices so it's
not just the water companies that we're
working with also working with the
landowners so these offices are they're
currently working on a
risk-based approach they look at the
sensitive sites
and the Agriculture and the landowners
that
work in those catchments and they go
around each of those Farms on regulatory
visits
and as they've covered that work they
will then start to stretch out into the
other parts of
that was additional funding from
Compares money farm farm advice and
Farmers section
so we got threat through the last
spending review
to deliver that additional work and
focus
that's it counts well that's it the
thing about in German you know
what can one say
Father Christmas
could I just add up to that sorry very
quickly
um is I guess one of the things that we
realize as a as the water industry is
that in the past I think all the sectors
were very focused on delivering what
they had to deliver in isolation and we
realized now that we can't do that we
have to work in partnership with with
highways with Farmers to actually
deliver this together because on the one
hand we want to build houses we want
growth to happen in the region but we
only have technically achievable limits
from the technology that's out there to
achieve certain standards of what's what
we're able to treat to so we realize now
that it's really really important for us
to work together to get to this good
standard because if we try and do it on
our own we are just not going to get
there
councilor Carter your question
thank you and thank you for the
presentation the flight time I've
written down the question from the first
slide I've forgot what was coming up in
the second one
um where to start um following on to
from councilor Madison's question
regards the false positives and dry
weather if there's false positives in
dry weather through outside influence
what guarantee do we have that there
isn't outside influence that means that
a actual OpenFlow event in wet weather
isn't being recorded
that's a very good question and we've
actually been really conservative about
how we've set up these devices so when
we first started to install them we were
very nervous about missing any storm
overflow spills so we did set them up
very conservatively which is probably
why we've ended up over reporting in a
number of cases however there is always
that risk that we may miss an overflow
event during a wet weather discharge or
when it shouldn't be happening and we
are working to try and make sure that
that doesn't have that that doesn't
happen we are using a verification
process now that doesn't just look at
one device anymore it actually looks at
multiple pieces of information in the
network and as I said we're trying we're
starting to employ
artificial intelligence and more data
intelligence systems to tell us whether
our devices are telling us exactly
whether they're spilling or not so we've
been working with a company called storm
Harvester and others to try and develop
systems so that we don't miss anything
at all but we are in a period of
learning and we do know that we're in a
situation where although we've set them
up conservatively there is some way to
go with regards to improving or accuracy
of monitoring but um as I say we've got
lots of verification systems out there
so we're not just using one piece of
information we're using rainfall we're
using borehole levels we're using River
levels and we're using multiple devices
to tell us yes device is operating as
expected or not
thank you
um links to that question this is going
to the environment agency
when you get a
a record or this overflow event I know
you'll be very means tested it depends
on what means relight you are
um what happens with regarding do you do
a full test in the rivers afterwards of
the quarter tests what what happens
afterwards
so that is based on the information that
we receive from Alien water we if it's
if it sounds very serious we send one of
our officers out who will go out and
take Downstream samples gather any
evidence that we would need to uh to
take an investigation forward
we obviously have a lot of experience of
these overflows and so if we think it's
been a short duration and hasn't
particularly had an impact on the water
course
say we're we're risk-based so we
wouldn't necessarily send an officer out
each time before that
but if it's severe an officer would go
out and take that investigation forward
and if it had if we find out it's had a
great environmental impact then we would
possibly take a case from well on that
basis
could there still be there's a small
event
could there still be a high
concentration of a harmful chemical or
substance within the events that might
not be recorded it might not be
recognized until the lifetime
so usually we would know an event from
either angling water and I know you
would send people out
um if also we we would look because if
there's things that aren't sewage like
in terms of that that there are other
chemicals and usually they might be
impacting on say the invertebrates we
would send a biologist out if we were
getting reports of anything that wasn't
looking well or was dying in the river
absolutely would go out that would add
to it to being serious so if there's any
reports of the little bugs starting to
die we will take that more seriously
so
I'm assuming I'm taking up a lot of time
just very quickly onto it I do have some
more but I'll never move on
we'll go to the end and then we can go
back again and see if there anymore it's
just a question in regards with the
additional plants life with the already
recorded lower invertebrates and things
like invisible
how visible is it going to be for things
dying off and if you can't see things in
the rivers with the wheat
so we if
if we get reports of people seeing
things floating or any and and often
there's minor ones is because we know
they're going into a dry ditch if we
felt there was something that had been
flowing for a while going into a river
then we would send someone out that's
where we would determine it was more
significant quite a lot of angling water
discharges may be into a dry Headwater
or dried ditch so therefore the the
ability for it to travel is limited the
ability to have any impact is limited
and that's when Ben says we would know
that that's what was going on in terms
of fish and smaller things yeah people
will should report them into us through
our instant hotline and also you know if
we had a significant enough discharge
from the volume or a duration then we'd
send someone out to look for those
things and they would look to see they
wouldn't you know you know would go
looking
and we have ecologists that would then
go out and do that to provide any
evidence as part of the investigation
to our evidence because of
the sanctions we have to prove Beyond or
Reasonable Doubt so we have expert
people that would go out and do that
monitoring
it's part of our case
that is harmful is ammonia and you can't
see ammonia but we help we have handheld
kits so we can test the ammonia levels
of the discharge so you can't see that
but we know that that's particularly
harmful go test
for that all there's no elevated levels
of ammonia being discharged in to the
river or upstream and downstream of our
discharge
that data is all shared with the
environment agencies
thank you I'll be good now
yes hello
um firstly I'd just like to say I'm
really pleased to hear about the efforts
to reduce the amount of phosphates going
into water because regarding the plant
life to have
to have to be worried about danger of
you know killing nesting birds and and
other animals and and also the member
for the other member for Hadley South so
we're very well represented and the
amounts of lemnum in the river I was
part of a community group we were
clearing that out last year and it's a
really it was a really smelly awful job
but uh so pleased to hear about that and
we're going to do it again properly this
year
um so my question is is that um
in 20 in April this year the government
said that they were going to ban wet
wipes next year
in 2024
um
are there are there any are there really
any wipes that are okay to flush like
non-plastic wipes and how can the public
be educated not to put rubbish down the
toilet
thank you for that question yeah I mean
as I said before wet wipes are the sort
of the being of our lives really and
angry wolf and other water companies now
the government of Southern said they're
going to ban them they're going to said
they're looking they're going to open
the consultation to ban the plastic in
wet wipes so wet wipes themselves I
think there's a place where it works
absolutely there's the right sort where
whites people in modern families uh care
system you know they rely on wet wipes
very much but as long as they're dealt
with properly and put them
similar campaign that water UK have
wished industry body have announced as
well called bin the wipe rather than
band The Wipe so so I think there is a
place for wet wipes um there is a flight
there is a fine to flush label on some
wet white product produced
um I think the jury's out on how fine to
flush they really are
um but you know we we would rather bin
the wipe than ban the wipes so but
certainly getting Plastics out of them
completely is that the consultation
that's part of the plant or water that's
been put forward
so in terms of communication we have a
ugly water have a scheme a campaign
called keep it clear so again if you
Google send your link around but keep it
clear as our sort of partnership
campaign to to remove what we call
unflashable so not just a wet wipes but
the fat cells and grease that combine
with the wet waps and cause those things
you know the fat bugs you've heard about
I'm sure of the years that block sewers
and cause pollutions and Spills so we do
a lot of work with food
establishments through a company called
ecas that we go around and monitor the
fat disposals the raw disposal of those
those companies and advise on how best
to use fat traps and capture those fats
and you can even recycle that oil and
sell it on as a product I know we're
looking at um you know people can use it
as biofuel and all sorts so there's the
market there that's growing all the time
um but ultimately it's education as you
said it's right and so we've got a
school program as well get the
generation coming forward to understand
about the impacts of those wet wipes and
that unflushable material and get them
to you know nag their parents and
hopefully change some behaviors that way
but we are it is a problem it's costing
us millions of pounds of years to clear
blockages
um and you know we
we are pushing as hard as we can so we
again I think that's attached earlier we
would really welcome support of local
authorities to help us share that
message I'm sure we can we can work
together to get that message out and
there's some really successful locals
games and initiatives that have
I know especially with kids they love
the gunk and the horrible smells and
that sort of thing so showing them and
putting a wet wipe in a bottle and a bit
of toilet roll and shaking up and
showing you the difference is quite
quite uh quite in you know
yeah happily to work together on the
castle on that
yeah that's great thank you sorry I got
I got it wrong about the wet wipes I had
realized that it was the plastic it's
just me
um is there any strategy for tackling
microplastic pollution I mean is that
possible I mean it's so tiny isn't it I
mean
what on Earth can be done about that
I think there is mentions of plastics
within the planet for water but
obviously at the moment that's still to
go through both houses of Parliament so
we're not totally sure well what Ultima
would that be but a lot of it is about
banning the product
rather than actually able to do much to
remove what's there
and so obviously you know we've all got
a part to play in terms of the products
we choose how choosing not to litter
managing litter because it's the erosion
of those that then leads to your
microplastics but I think there's going
to be more focus on
certain products and chemicals being
banned through that plan for water but
until that's regulation and those
actions aren't taking but as we go along
you know there are things that
increasingly are being banned and that
focus on plastic needs to be maintained
removing them it's like some of the
other thing that yeah yeah the best
thing is a bit like the phosphate we
need to get back to not putting so much
on the land only putting what we need
thinking about the phosphate content of
other products that we might be putting
down
our existing process does take out as
much plastic can
we I was going to offer at the end of
the meeting but if any of you would like
to come
see one of our water cycle centers we'll
happily show you around and show you
what we do and how we work with removing
Plastics and we have skips full of the
stuff that we have to take off to
landfill and our meshes that filter that
incoming if effluent are getting Tighter
and Tighter to remove as much micro
plastic as we can but ultimately the
smaller bits do get through and they end
up possibly in the sludge treatment
process and then back maybe back onto
land so as salicer says there's no
regulations around that yet but again
we're working together to try and get to
that point but but really
the answer is not getting in the
environment in the first place so your
choice is about what you buy and how
products you use uh really are the way
to remove Plastics
thank you
councilor Smith
I don't know
which one oh no
thank you thank you
morning
um
I'm very pleased to see that there's a
lot more public the public data
available to the public I noticed that
and I'm really excited to hear about
your real-time reporting map
um you mentioned the phosphorus
games
but you didn't mention Sudbury I
represent sub reward
um I saw on the website that Sudbury
water recycling center
is was due to have a phosphorus removal
equipment installed this year
um
could could you confirm whether that has
happened
sorry yes
um
so there is one should do a Sudbury I
have missed some of my lists apologies
there's a Sudbury um phosphorus scheme
which is due to be implemented by
December 2024.
all right I didn't read them all out I
was just trying to scroll through my
list and I I can actually share that
full list
that's fine I only ask because on the
website it said
it was due to finish
by this summer it's obviously been set
back so I was going to ask about that
specifically anyway but I can actually
check when it's finished because I think
what we get in our water industry
program is a an obligation date that we
may just try and deliver it before that
obligation date so it's possible that
it's finished early but I'll can double
check that for you okay thank you it's
good news either way but the sooner the
better
um and also in Sudbury in regards to the
the bathing status application
um I know that Anglia Motors supporting
the application and you've enabled
um citizen scientists with water
monitoring I belong to another group
that
more monitors the river stower in
Sudbury and we've been testing for E
coli and found quite high levels in in
the bathing status area and I believe
anglian water has two
um I just wondered
what what will it mean if
hopefully we get the application and we
get the status granted what will that
mean on the ground
if the E coli levels are still high when
the river is tested
so
applications successful this Autumn it
will go into I think um
the sun was explained through the
restrust we'll go into the monitoring
program so we then on behalf of the
government undertake the monitoring so
we'll get that E coli there's another
indicator pathogen indicator that we
also look for
um and then we are able to report those
we publish those results as they come
out so you'll just be more informed
about the level of E coli in the river
then if that is not with
not with standard so at the end of that
year the government will issue the
classification for that bathing water
we can help Drive investment by the
water companies looking I mean
plan for water will drive much of this
anyway through the changes to storm
overflows but you have to remember even
treated sewage has E coli in it
so it's not just storm flows treated
sewage agriculture cows Birds anything
warm-blooded is putting those things in
um and you also have to remember that E
coli is just an indicator of a whole
group of pathogens so when you look at
the bathing water regulations
so when they go out to seaweed we
monitor E coli because you cannot detect
viruses adequately in the environment
but what the water company are able to
do is track a reduction in viral load
through their treatment which is where
we can show that UV demonstrates
a real Improvement to minimizing the
risk to to human health
so it's it needs an even higher level of
treatment if you're going to do that but
it may be in a river catchment we don't
fully know all of those sources so one
of the things we can do in the
environment agency
is
if a sample is hyped during that year we
might be able to then take some of that
E coli
DNA of it it is a one-off snapshot and
it's a very expensive piece of analysis
so we don't offer it very routinely it
comes to about 900 000 pounds to just do
the one
um but you can get an idea of what might
be contributing to the pathogen load and
you get an idea of whether you know it
is just or human or whether there's
other ruminants or other things that are
contributing but then if you want to
bring it down yes we can drive
investment at the sewage works and as I
said I think the plan for water will do
quite a lot that anyway it'll be about
again looking at those other sources so
it you know it will be managing dog
litter it could be managing and I know
know on some Coastal ones there's been
you know keeping an eye on the seagulls
don't feeding the seagulls campaign
because it's actually doing that has
improved the quality of the bathing
water
and it will also be working with farmers
and looking at how and when they're
spreading them up on their fields
because obviously if they do that it
rains and they have this there's better
farming practices so cows will be a big
source of E coli and obviously many of
them
of them try and work with them and how
we can prevent access to the rivers so
it's a very complicated picture once you
get into a river but what the status
will do is it allows a driver for that
to be looked at and it will allow
perhaps a driver for investment
from a favor's point of view we you said
the classification so at the end of the
year there'll be an announcement of what
that classification is from a bathing
point of view there's a
sweet every time we take a sample it's
published on there so you can go in and
as soon as it's available to us it's on
the website and you can see what those
concentrations are like from our
analysis if we are um aware of it
particularly so on on where we've got
some Coastal beaches which is obviously
where we've got the most experience
because that's where most of them are if
we know the quality of that bathing
water is particularly driven
may not be sewage sometimes it's catches
on a certain Beach we can put out
Advanced warnings to the public through
the website but also the local Authority
has a responsibility for a bathing water
in terms of signing and warning the
public so we'd be working closely with
you if we were aware of if if a bathing
water was linked to rainfall events or
we were aware of a pollution event in
the river we'd obviously be in touch so
that you were able to wall inform the
users of that bathing water so we'll
have a closer working relationship as a
result of that bathing water
thank you yeah
okay can I just remind everybody that we
can't have lights on there can only be
one light for the um
the microphones on at one time it does
detract from the sound so if you just
remember when you're not speaking to
turn your microphone off thank you very
much uh councilor Wyman
thank you chair
um worth waiting for I hope my questions
first I'd like to thank the the
witnesses of the panel for a great
presentation really detailed and clearly
a very very complicated and uh detail
subject because there's I mean land use
is is obviously a major part of
the overall conversation in relation to
knock on pollution Etc into our rivers
and in sewers and I do think it's a bit
of a shame that defer aren't present
today because they are Central to quite
a few of the things that you know we
often talk about which you guys have to
link in with also with the people from
from Natural England so I mean my first
question really relates to land use
and I'm really interested to know where
we are with things like catchment
sensitive farming but also particularly
and you mentioned it Alice in just a few
moments ago um E coli and how we
actually monitor
um and it's not mainly in within this
District Council area but certainly
within the southern Coastal
um the runoff from uh outside pig farms
because obviously you know it's quite a
big thing now there's extensive Peak
production on the sort of light bands of
the code
and if I'm completely honest if you
drive by you difficult to understand how
it's possible to estimate or calculate
what the E coli and orangular pathogens
that are running off from those areas
into our into our systems particularly
into for example the diva catchment and
and the like that's that's the question
wondering I'd also like to invite Nick
to comment on us from a natural England
perspective
sensitive farming I'll hand over to Nick
but just a quick one in terms of
agriculture we would be
um
advising Farmers on how best to operate
their
you know their Farm whether that's an
intensive Pitfall intensive chicken farm
we want to involve them and what they're
doing with the waste from those farms
and I think you're right that you know
free-range pegs we get involved with
pollution incidents from those so with
the successive runoff we will get
involved because it it's not so much the
E coli there's other it has um quite a
high oxygen Demand on a river if it gets
in because it's very biological so it
hits the river it will use up a lot of
oxygen so we do give a lot of advice and
guidance around
intensive farming and pigs and outdoor
pigs I know have been challenging I
think Ben would agree with me but we
work with them on their practice and
um but um
and if there are instance then we would
take action
sorry I should put in Alice and how do
you control it I mean there seems to be
no no way of actually having you've got
no lever that you can apply like you can
with lots of other things where you've
got a pollution incident there seems to
be no leave that you can use to actually
control that
sorry we have uh several pieces of
legislation
that are our leavers for bringing those
pig farms back into compliance so the
the regulatory officers are referred to
earlier on that is their remit so we my
team from Norfolk and Suffolk might
respond to the pollution incident so
we'd look at the enforcement side and
looking to take that case on and
he fines or anything that the courts May
hand down but on the other side you've
got the the advice sides coming from the
regulatory officers who are then engaged
with that farmer and sailor
you're not compliant with their nvz
regulations all the farming rules for
water this is where your non-compliance
is lie this is what you need to bring
your farm back into compliance so we
it's probably one of our better served
regimes agriculture at the moment in
terms of the levers we do have
thanks I was going to mention nv6 I
thought probably MV Zeds has sort of
Gone by the way so years ago but
um
surely there must be a conversation with
government to use in the
agri-environment schemes to try and help
farmers manage this better you know by
you know a lamb better buffer strips and
you know and actually not rewarding them
but incentivizing Farmers to do that and
sorry my second question which sort of
relates to this to some extent really is
um
you mentioned at Water abstraction and
the demands on water abstraction
generally
um should we not be looking more closely
again at incentivizing Pharmacists for
things like winter catchment so we can
then try and withdraw some of the
abstraction licenses that we can
withdraw and at the same time encourage
Farmers to have more winter catchments
so there aren't the demands on the
rivers such as you know the abstraction
say on the river Stewart which you know
the gentleman from from
from somebody mentioned there must be
better ways of doing it certainly
encouraging that incentivization of
building and construction
so there is support for winter storage
reservoirs but obviously they need
planning but there is incentivization I
think the government's just recently
closed a round of people being able to
apply for
for Port to build into storage
reservoirs so that does happen and we
absolutely actively encourage winter
storage reservoirs to protect the
environment that is the way to go and
increasingly if the rain's going to fall
in Winter then they should have that to
get them through the summer you know
crops we grow are very water intensive
so we very much you know restrict the
amount they abstract and we very much
work with the Farmers on putting those
schemes in where there has been
supplemental funding I was just going to
say it might be worth naturally than
just speaking a little bit on the other
incentives and buffer strips
strict can we hear from Nick Nicholas
thank you
thank you yep
um
yes as I alluded there
Spectrum sensitive farming is yet we
have
farming officer offices their advisors
sorry change of change of um
change the title um catchment sensitive
farming advisors in your area
it's
the the whole area is covered now by an
advisor but that whole area is only
being covered by an advisor in the last
two years because prior to that
um if there was a prioritization driven
that was that only included the sort of
north end of your your areas that feeds
into the wave knee catchment however now
there is
a catchment sensitive farming advice
across your whole area
with farming it takes a while to build
the relationships and build the trust to
get the actions delivered on the ground
so some of them posted two years that's
starting to make an impact but it's yeah
it takes time and we understand that the
thing with catchment sensitive farming
as a standalone
piece of work is providing advice but it
doesn't provide sort of compulsion shall
we say um
some of that sort of if we get to the
point of something needing compulsion
because advice hasn't worked it then
falls into various regulatory regimes as
has already been described by the
environment agency
um or Natural England can take
regulatory action with appropriate
evidence where it's affecting protected
sites
um so yeah there is also if we relate to
um you're mentioning the coastal and the
demon
catchment sensitive farming advisors are
working with the demon Farm cluster
which is a partnership with rivers
trusts and others to actually improve
that
the
the management before the water
environment across the Farms within the
farm cluster which is something very
much encouraged because obviously that
catchment you really do need to work at
scale rather than on almost rather than
on an individual Farm basis
um agri-environment schemes countries
and stewardship
both the mid tier and the higher tier
have options which farmers can choose to
implement to reduce runoff and improve
soil structure to reduce runoff but also
put buffer strips in cover cropping is
another activity that's very much
encouraged through those schemes
um again they are voluntary schemes but
there is compensation for that or
something that come with funding there
are
conversations can be had as to the
the relative prioritization of doing
these measures but versus other land
uses which don't
provide that level of Environmental
Protection but that's always always a
scheme with any sort of funded scheme is
it enough it's taxpayers money
ultimately as well and the payment rates
are set
um within
that's for I believe and in conjunction
with the rural payments agency who run
the schemes that Natural England
advisors advise both on the higher tier
schemes which have a lot of Natural
England input in and attachment
sensitive farming advisors can advise on
the mid-tier schemes
which is predominantly put together by
individual Farmers
um but that's why I would sort of go
back to the earlier point and very much
encouraged by yet the request for
getting some information from the
councilor earlier about
um
understanding the types of measures that
can go in place to
help protect the water environment
through these schemes and
sort of the point in my mind on this is
there's a sort of a relatively small
Suite of relatively well-known and
understood measures that can be
implemented across the across the board
who make a difference so buffer strips
The Wider the better the more tusaki
broad sort of three-dimensional is a
sort of technical phrase but basically
the more tasky they are the slower the
water moves the more sediment and it's
particularly the sediment with the
phosphate that takes the phosphate into
the rivers that can be addressed there's
also actions within that move gateways
from the sort of bottom corner of a
field so it all rushes out the bottom
corner move gateways higher up and so
the runoff doesn't just charge out
through a Gateway so it's quite a lot of
within the scheme there's quite a lot of
practical measures that can be
undertaken and that are funded to
undertake those measures
but yeah it's
there's still work to do and there's
yeah
more advice that goes out to Farmers to
do this and the more encouraged they are
the better overall
can I thank you for the response
yeah because let's add quickly to that
yeah so yeah a couple of points um
abstraction and the challenge that we
face in the region
um there's a couple of things Water
Resources East is an organization I'd
point you towards which covers a lot of
stuff what Nicholas has said basically
about Water Resource Management in East
Anglia and including farming and other
industry and all the water companies
which are we're a part of and a lot of
other organizations are part of the
other point on abstraction is that you
know we're bringing more water to the
region so we've got our strategic
pipeline which is coming from
Lincolnshire which you might have heard
about which ends up in Suffolk and Essex
which is going to be our biggest water
pipe we've ever built which should be in
commissioned by 2025 but again that's
bringing more water into East anglian
certainly in the South uh to combat the
attraction challenges we've got as as I
mentioned we ever need to protect the
environment so we are doing a lot of
that investment too and I'll just walk
through cycling but on freshwater
provision as well so that's why I'll add
that in thank you
thank you sir can I just add another
very quickly
um yes it was just in the following up
from the point of
um
abstractions and winter storage yes
we're very much support of that and have
worked in particular cases with the
environment agency and water company to
build that I think there is sort of we
need also there's a
value in sort of stepping back even
further and looking and relating that to
flood issues and capturing that flood
water which isn't is more complicated
but I think it's something we do need to
be looking forward looking towards in
the future
um and that relates to things like local
nature recovery strategies and some of
these slightly longer term and broader
scale approaches as well
okay
thank you
thank you sir
um it's always it's not the very last
but I will put it in here
um I come out of a history of Health
Care and
happens
is there any discussion with
pharmaceutical companies before they
actually produce drugs as to what might
be the end result and what
waterways and the sewage system thank
you
I don't think that's either of our
specialism but that may well be
happening and I know we get involved
with chemicals through defra and
government in terms of yes there's a lot
of work going on in terms of chemicals
what should be banned what should be
reduced when should it be used
um
so I cannot give you specifics on the
development of new
Pharmaceuticals but Pharmaceuticals is a
is a is an area of growing I suppose
interest and concern well it's
sort of needs further
you know investigation I think actually
thank you
um
very sorry but councilor Mellon did have
a question but unfortunately he had to
go and councilor Mathison you're going
to ask the questions on his behalf
aren't you thank you thank you Jeff
um yeah I have got um
it's a question is for our officers
planning officers particularly but I've
also wanted to propose that as we've
been going for two hours that we do have
a comfort Break
um and also
um that we need a little time to
consider some recommendations
and also
just to go ahead for a moment that I I'd
be asking one of our recommendations
would be that we
um that we submit some further questions
to our external Representatives
um as it's obviously been very good to
have them here and um but there is there
is yet more to there is yet more to ask
I think
um so if we could have a couple of break
before we tackle that a lot and no I get
what I'd like to do councilor Mathison
I'd already discussed that with
um Alicia if we just finished the how
many questions have you gone
well
um as a couple on on the on the planning
offices particularly
um really looking looking back to the
um the motion that we passed last
November
um I was wondering you know what to what
extent we've managed to to actually
Implement
um firstly there's the question of
evidence
um for
um our future allocations in the joint
local plan
which seems to be Mr Barker's um
question and
um but also to to what extent are we
managing to get the information
um the additional information
um into into our planning reports that
go to the committee and the um you know
from anger and water and
um and highlighting that aspect in the
the case officers reports which is
perhaps for both of you
I think actually I mean I quite agree
with you counselor Mathison we need a
break
are there so apart from those questions
are there any other questions from the
committee that
councilor Carter
well I think it would be useful that
does mean though that we everybody needs
to come back including our guests
so I'm sorry about that is that okay
we we need we need to leave quite soon
but depends how I mean it depends how we
can get through these things now and we
got to make a decision as a community
we our guests are on limited time do we
ask them the planning question can be
asked afterwards to our
well we're more than happy to take
written questions afterwards to get back
to you absolutely no
problem
are there any questions that need to be
addressed to our guests because we
account
but we'll have to make them very quick
okay
councilor Smith do you want to go now
um thank you chair
um
the uh back to Sudbury
um we there's an application for an
artificial Sports pitch that the
football club which has caused a bit of
concern I know sub-reter and Council
have
for a bit more information about
um
potential collusion and I believe
believe anglian mortar are sponsoring
that or funding it
um
is is that a good idea if there is a
concern around
pollution
I don't know about that particular left
look into that that's first I've heard
of it so we'll get back to you on that
one
but no you don't know that's fine thank
you
um
in your Preamble Grant you mentioned
rainwater and
um that it needn't go through the sewage
system it could go straight into the
subsoil yeah
would it be two too Grand a scheme to
um
change our existing
existing drainage
to to drain into ballast or other
in short yes it'll be re-plumbing into
our houses and all sorts but certainly
new developments aren't built that way
anymore so it should be separate water
and sorry service water and foul systems
in place again you accuse the planning
system but yeah yeah unfortunately yeah
there's this there's so many existing
properties with surface water
connections on on into into file systems
that that would be possible to fix all
of them what we do do we encourage
people to save water put water butts in
attenuate that flow if even if it still
goes into the into the fast system we
can slow it down that helps as well so
having water Baths on your house collect
that free rain water for your garden
will always help as well so we do we do
encourage people to do that
councilor Carter
thank you
um I also have a questions from
councilor Mellon they do overlay with
mine I'm happy to for them to be read
quickly
um or shall I just read my own
um because both of them need
your staff are you addressing them to
the guests yes okay then we can
control questions certainly yes we are
but they are questions to the guests
um
right
should I read my own or should I recast
on that that's better that's my question
right because I know it's councilor
Madison was going to ask him but
regards the
planet and
we do consult with anglian water
regarding applications even though
they're not statutory control t
um other infrastructure providers being
Education Health Service ask for
contributions when large housing
developments are applied for
why doesn't Anglia water do anything
sorry what was what was the question why
don't angry mortar
um our other
infrastructure of infrastructure
providers I can't even pronounce the
words of the teeth and eventually
Education Health Service Etc ask for
contributions when large housing
developments go up
um get yourself starts is there a reason
why you don't ask for contributions well
we do we do ask for contribution from
developer under section 106 so that part
of that payment is paid to England water
into a pot and then that money's then
split to where the most impact can be
come from it so it might not necessarily
be in that local vicinity if we don't
need any work but that goes into a fund
that is used to add mitigation to
encourage
of services we can provide so there is
there is a fund that comes from
developers yes
okay what triggers
um yourselves to invest in new
infrastructure when significant housing
is built in a catchment of a water
treatment works
so we
can see of the development and then we
will assess that capacity against
what load it is bringing into the
downstream water recycling center that
water recycling center has got the
capacity to treat that load then we know
we don't need to invest if it does
doesn't have the capacity to treat that
load then we will invest to put more
treatment processes in place on that
works to treat it and then we also look
at flow as well so it might be that we
can treat the load but not the volume so
we will look at the volume that's
required that from that extra
development and then we will invest as
required if there's not enough capacity
in the network or at the downstream
water recycling center
so that just drives us so the thing that
actually then the thing that actually
drives us to invest will be whatever the
permit is that we've been issued by the
environment agency and if we know we're
going to discharge more flow
into that receiving Watercourse we go
back to the environment agency and we
say we want to now discharge this much
flow because of this development that's
happening Upstream then the environment
agency will issue us a new permit with
tighter standards so we don't cause
deterioration in that receiving
Watercourse and therefore we investor
treat that additional volume and we also
then invest to treat that load to meet
the new permit standard issued by the
environment agency
um part of my own question Garden it's
been noted that we we've had unusual dry
free years
and
I wonder personally if there's a overlay
map between the storms and water in our
area and the state reduction in the The
Water waste
um I did one that was being written by
councilor Merlin who is um
the top overflows in our area in 2022
which was a very dry year uh were 658
hours and at Stoneham our school
568 hours at fonden and 443 hours at the
badwell ash
when will these sort of figures be
reduced
so those storm overflows operate in
response to rainfall events so if we
have more localized rainfall events then
those storm overflows will operate more
frequently now we are building more
storm storage and we're increasing our
treatment capacity our works to reduce
those storm spills so that will help so
if we had the same number of storm
events happening this year in comparison
to previous years since the storm
storage has been built then those number
of events of releases to the environment
will overall reduce but we do have to
make sure that we're protecting
businesses and homeless from flooding
and that's why these storm overflows
operate so there is um there are systems
like metiamatics there are rain gauges
out in our Network so anybody has access
to those data sets to be able to see
when and how often rainfall occurs but
the biggest thing that we're challenged
with at the moment is the climate change
these flash events that are happening
that are quite localized in our
catchments and therefore storm overflows
are going to operate as of when we get
those really heavy short rainfall events
happening
but yes our long-term plan is to reduce
harm from Storm overflows increase the
storage in our capacities but also
remove this rainfall from Lost systems
so that we don't operate them as much as
we do now
and the final question from Angie Mellon
from councilman which I do absolutely
love because I've been rather bogged
down by figures to Garden
Investments and shareholders and the
dividends but isn't the truth that's
Anglia mortis has prioritized paving at
playing out dividends to shareholders
rather than investing in infrastructure
I can answer that that way I mean
categorically no uh our investment model
is that shareholders are invest in the
company and they haven't actually taken
dividend until last year for the
previous five years so they've
reinvested what shareholders value they
would have back in the business uh
they're also investing putting more
money directly into angling water as
well as alongside our money we get from
yourselves as Bill payers to drive
further environmental improvements so
that there is no relation between
stakeholders shareholders and investment
in fact you can say the opposite they
they're investing more rather than
taking more out of the business but yeah
it's all public it's in our annual
report you can see all the figures this
year
well thank you I can share the figures
that I have later yeah
thank you councilor Carter councilor
Mathison did you have any questions for
the guests
no Focus for the guests
but you do have questions for flying
officers okay uh latest
um
committee members I'm drawing this
session to a close for a break
we're still in question time so we come
back and we've got we've come back at 12
o'clock
is that long enough
does anybody knows that's long enough
is that okay
can I before we go can I just thank
we need to thank
our guests for an excellent
presentations I want to thank Grant and
Natasha from anglian water Ben and
Alison from the environment agency
Nicholas from Natural England and John
from the river star trust thank you very
much for answering our questions I'm
sorry it's gone on quite a long time but
I knew it was going to be a lengthy
question session but thank you very much
you're very welcome thank you
uh we I think there's only your
questions councilor Mathison but we'll
start with you okay thank you thank you
very much chair
um yeah I was
um one of the members
um who
in the old Council as it were voted for
the the motion last November
um which
um which gave rise to this this hearing
we've had today as as uh the first
paragraph of the of the um resolution
um which is good so really I wanted to
ask
um Mr Barker it's a director
um you know how
how far and how well we are
um Gathering evidence
for the local plan
um about the cumulative impact of sewage
um when deciding the overall level of
Housing and other development and
um
and that the water cycle study updated
um would be
informing the decisions about
allocations which I know is sort of part
two of The Joint local plan
now
um and um
you know so are we
are we actively doing that I think is my
question
thank you councilor um so to confirm
some evidence Gathering to inform part
two of The Joint local plan is underway
but not related to these specific issues
and as soon as we move as soon as we
move into
part two of the plan
Earnest then absolutely we'll get into
this and and look at the updated water
cycle study and work with colleagues
with other stakeholders including
anglian water including northumbrian
water including the environment agency
in Natural England to ensure that this
issue is something that is considered as
we're looking at part two of the plan
which will include housing allocations
yeah so I mean the
I'd assume we were already working on
part two in the effects and um so
sometime soon
as I said some evidence Gathering has
already commenced and been commissioned
that will inform part two but not in
respect of this specifically yet but it
will
if I carry on to my other other question
which which stems from um
part three and four of the of the motion
which I think was unanimously passed at
Mid Suffolk and
um certainly got past it babe everybody
in favor of it were they generally
I was just wondering it was unanimously
past baber as well wasn't it
you know I can see there's people
nodding behind you
um yeah so the the point there really
was
um that we
that we would ask
um angling water
to to actually tell us which treatment
works would be managing
um the the sewage outfall of any
particular
um application uh obviously we talked
about major applications here really
um and um you know and about their
capacity to treat
um
and
you know and about the the
the the level of these
um overflows that we've been talking
about this morning
um and you know and the um
you know and yeah I see it notes that we
can only request this not require it but
nevertheless are we are we getting it
and then related to that is the fourth
the fourth paragraph
um which asks that planning officers
um include this information and you know
discussion of it in there
um in their report as a specific section
and
um I'm not kind of immediately feel as
if that's that's coming in front of the
planning see so if you if you could give
us a bit of reassurance that that's uh
happening
yeah I'm happy to answer that councilor
Mathison um yes in short notwithstanding
that we already were Consulting angling
water on major applications following
the motion of November last year and we
amended our consultation request
template such that we asked those
targeted questions of anglian water from
then on and then what we do is what we
get back we report to members through
the the committee and decision taking
process to confirm that I'm grateful for
the break I had a look at one of the
items that went to committee last month
in Thurston for 112 houses and it was
the case there that yes would send that
consultation request
we received a relatively folsome
response from angling water and that was
reported in full in the committee report
remember members who ultimately then
took a decision
good right thank you and I I suppose the
um are we discussing it in the balance
or can we discuss it in the balance of
the material consideration really would
be my supplement
um well that's that's a more difficult
one to answer because it really depends
upon the circumstances generally
speaking if um you've consulted angling
water they raise no objection they have
capacity they're happy that there's a
suitable connection that will be made
um they offer up suitable planning
conditions
um then broadly speaking the assessment
of an application will relate solely to
the land use involved and this is 188
power 188 to the mppf you then assume or
you will presume that statutory regimes
other regimes will operate efficiently
so that's the point really where
development management ends and then the
roles and duties of those those other
guests that you've heard from and
questioned this morning will come into
play
is that your last question
um I'm not sure who to you know this is
just to the council generally
um is there anything more that we as a
council can do to change public Behavior
around litter putting rubbish down
toilets and also the need to install
water baths to reduce rain water
overwhelming sewers because that last
point there was nothing I had that
hadn't occurred to me I mean is there
anything
that we can do you know funding cheap
water butts or public information
something on the website that sounds to
me like a
something to be debated as a group as a
committee so can you hang on to that
was there another question councilor
Wyman
follow-up question to to Stephen really
from from councilman's boy
are there any do we get any information
from sanglion water on cumulative impact
in communities where there's a gradual
growth of of housing you know so you've
gone from sort of five to ten to 20 to
100 Etc because some small villagers
don't have massive sort of sewage
facilities and the impact on these would
be quite significant do we get any
follow-up information on cumulative
impact from angling water
um it it off off the top of my head I
can't think of a specific example but
I'm sure that those situations can and
do occur which is why I think as the
representatives from angling water
mentioned
um they have on occasion sought section
106 contributions that assuming they
meet the cell tests I.E that they're
necessary to make that development
acceptable and are directly related to
it then we can secure them and then one
would imagine that that's going into a
pot to then solve those cumulative
issues that you're alluding to
castle of all boys
thank you chair yes
um
there's a question really about targeted
questions
um
from what we've heard and from last
year's planning committee in my
assumption is that stowmarket
sewage treatment center is at or above
capacity it's no longer got the capacity
to deal with the present
out food
I have a feeling that I searched
treatment plant is is approaching that
because there's been huge development
there and
I can go past I see which plant
regularly and I see no development
taking place I would assume it's just as
it was 40 years ago
can we
request
information regarding development of
these sewage treatment plants specific
information as to
we've heard about
plans for development can we ask for
where this development is actually
taking place and how it's going to
mitigate the current situation
sorry Council of War boys you mean
anglian water development yes
um well I think that the when we say
targeted questions that we put to
angling water in our consultation
requests I mean they follow the precise
wording of the motion I think if you
feel that they're not specific or
brought or indeed broad enough in Ambit
then that's something we could we could
potentially look at
can I can I just say that if because our
guests had to go
um if you do have some questions that
you want directing at them I think if
you email Alicia she will actually
forward those questions on your behalf
yeah that'd be really useful I think
because you know I think we could have
spent longer here today but time is a
yes that's fine thank you
members we're now in a period of debate
oh sorry
counselor Carter I can't see you at the
back
apologies when playing again musical
chairs I cheat with my scooter right um
I did have a question when it comes to
we've had this with our professori
bodies or outside um bodies where we
have the records but they are giving us
what back up what do we have as a as a
council
what confirmations do we have for the
facts and figures but we are getting are
accurate do we do our home follow-up
tests and what measures do we have if
they are if there are if there are
outside infants such as a water runoff
going against what we've stated in a
Planning Development or if a state that
they can make capacity and it's not what
Fallout measures do we do as a planning
body or do we do if they they've stated
they're going to make a
additional sewage um things and it
doesn't happen what what back up do we
have following later
it's sort of a question that's within
the rumbling
who would like to answer that
or do you want to transcripts
well I think in terms of looking at the
at the evidence that's not one I can
answer so well because clearly it's not
necessarily going to be in a planning
officer's gift to know
um whether the Fig is being presented to
them by a statutory console t or a
developer are correct so that's why we
Rely Upon Our expert consulties to
provide their opinions such as for
instance the lead local flood Authority
in respect of service water drainage
matters
from a um from a local planning
Authority perspective
if it's the case that a particular
strategy for drainage has been approved
um and usually that's either through the
full plans as part of the planning
permission or by approval of details
reserved by planning condition if if a
developer is not meeting those
requirements and that is potentially an
Enforcement issue
councilor Carter did that answer your
question
I believe so thank you is that right
we're now in debate
members
who would like to start the debate
Council of War boys
okay yeah
um
yes I do feel a sense of frustration
slightly that we didn't quite get
the sort of clarity we wanted
um
and there are serious
public questions about this really about
the current
capacity
of the of Anglia water to deal with the
the current outflows the problems caused
by Future development
[Music]
um
the we're in the as as we were told
we're in the driest region you know and
we again we were told by where was it
2055 we'll grab a new water supply
um
you know it it is frustrating and I
think you know
I've tried to push for more clarity in
the planning department I know I've
planning offices
work really hard and we're Bound by
Statute in regulations and I think
I'm not certain that public actually
understands this at our hands are tied
um
the
there was a lot of issues about the the
quality of our river waters about
bathing Waters I visited um
a surge outflowing disc which I know is
out outside our area but it's close to
me and it was being it had been water
sampled there which is why I was alone
from the river Waverly Trust
and there was uh salmonella in the water
a resident in the garden there
changing the water filters as regularly
as they used to it smells more and
certainly by my own you know my own nose
told me that that water was really in a
terrible state
um my concerns are about Public Safety
um
I used to swim in rivers there's
certainly some bits of some Rivers I
wouldn't even touch never mind going
um the water samples were being taken
with gloves on which saves enough my
concerns about members of the public
dogs might go in the water
children might retrieve balls from the
water
um
and become ill as a result of it
there are no public warning notices
about
these Waters of the vicinity of these
outflows which I think is something
perhaps we we could address as a council
where we got to warning the public about
specific
areas which I think people know about
but perhaps that knowledge needs to be
shared with the public
um
I'd certainly sort of look as we go into
the local plan and and the sort of
strategic development and how that
relates to Water Supplies
um I realized uh
offices are
I've got very restrictive powers to
actually gain more information about
what the water board is doing to
safeguard our water supplies
under and to deal with the millions of
liters of extra
sewage that is going into our system
um
I I just I after a walk with
um counselor Carter was saying I just
wonder if there is
scope for us as a council under under
Freedom of Information to get more
information from
the current strategies of the water
board and the projected
plans we know the money we know there's
money coming in I guess the the build
the water bill players are going to be
paying for it
um which I think is is you know the big
question I I get asked you know the
people with their water bills they're
paying larger and larger water bills
they're going to be asked to pay
for improvements
to that Supply
and yet the I was astounded when um it
was said that there was
no connection between investment and
pain
shareholders
and I I found that quite difficult to um
put together in my head really that
people are making a profit but they're
not investing so
a sense of frustrated I'm not quite
satisfied we got what we wanted from
them I think this is round one I think
we will have to sort of firm up our
questions and perhaps get around to
oh stop now
thank you Council of all boys
well just really just to um to begin to
to frame one or two recommendations I
mean I think
clearly from what council War boys just
saying
um that we
um that we we recommend that of that um
a further
um
set of questions is is compiled
um with contributions from members
either members present or not present
because there's quite a few members of
scrutiny committee that were not able to
be here today
um and um you know just to send those to
the to the various
um organizations
and then subsequently published those in
in the um in the information bulletin
um of the committee
um and the specifics really I think just
to
um to reiterate the
um the Motions from last November
um you know as as the new councils as we
are now
um and it's it's reassuring that they
are going ahead and
um I think there's
there's very specifics really
um is
that we pick up that point about the wet
wipes without plastic are
urgently needed and I I quote from
anglian water they are they are the bane
of our life
he said
and um
so I I think to Jimmy the government up
um on that point specifically would be
um would be something that the council
can do and
um
and I I'm I wondered whether any anybody
is able to
confirm that the fifth point on the the
Motions
um was about lobbying local MPS and off
what
um with our concerns about water quality
and we shouldn't see improvements and so
on
whether such letters were written and
whether answers came back and it's
fortunes is that we have the the chair
of the district council amongst us today
um so he'd be able to write a new round
of letters on our behalf I guess whether
that has to go through full Council or
not
um I I don't honestly know
um whether that can come straight from
this committee or or whether we need to
um
to get the full Council to agree as well
but certainly
um I thought it was quite striking
how firmly that particular question was
answered
thank you councilor Mathison we're
looking at your repeating the Motions
that were created by this
the previous administration for new
members actually on the paper that we've
got in front of us
it was quite simple the invitation to so
I think we need to clarify what it is we
want to achieve but before we go on to
the recommendations are there any other
members that would like to just make a
comment
councilor Courthouse yeah this is just
um reiterating what I said earlier on
about whether or not we can do more to
inform the public about not putting
stuff down the toilets I mean what about
signs in public lose on the door
something anything to get the message
across and and again about about you
know water butts things like that I mean
it hadn't occurred to me I have loads of
water belts to save water I hadn't ever
thought about it going into the sewage
and overflowing it and I dare say most
people don't think about that so I don't
know if there's if there's anything that
can come out of this meeting that could
through things
councilor Marriott
so regarding this um reducing phosphates
that they mentioned several terms Hadley
Norton elmswell Sudbury and debenham I
would like to think that it was going to
go out to other areas this is just a
sort of pilot
um I think there are lots of areas in
Suffolk in mid-suffolk that could do
with monitoring at that level and and
just a quick word as well I think we've
given been given a lot more to worry
about really the emotions of pathogen
levels liquid oxygen levels and ammonia
levels
um so
I think where it is possible to do any
sort of local testing of water I
should investigate that thank you
councilor Carter
uh thank you I'd like to share councilor
Rollins frustration with what we had
today as well
um
as wonderful as the demonstration was at
a start it was a quite distraction from
what made question many questions may
have been in the future have
given more
um
having spoken to the environment agency
before and knowing what Strife stress we
are in at the moment not able to do
testing unnecessarily uh
comes through where it's actually a
problem showing a problem if I don't do
regular testing they're having funds to
do so
and having spoken to The Rivers trusts
the invertebrates
um whether they're doing things and the
figures but they are taking their tests
are not being fed into government
figures there could be a major problem
going on and we wouldn't know about it
and we wouldn't know about it until it's
too late so that does concern me
and it concerns me that I myself have
fallen into a red herring here with the
overflows concentrating on that when we
don't know if the
durability of the instructor but we'd
have
and could there be other issues going on
to increase the nitrates and preset from
the Water Works of it aren't just due to
water overflow
so I would be very keen to have a good
support have been back again in the
future
um and I did during a break managed to
show the figures to the angling water
and a kite was a visible figure sort of
connected by Suffolk County Council and
quite was I don't recognize these
figures
so it doesn't mean if we could collect
our own data and do a bit more
work in advance next time it's my fault
as well maybe we have a different answer
to next time around
so I'd
I'd support looking really looking at
say the recommendations of last time
and also supports bringing them back
again when we've got a bit we've had
round one
it'd be nice to get a second puncher
thank you chair
um I think we all need to remember that
we represent two large agricultural
communities both midsummic and vapor and
also to some extent uh college to the
north
um
many of the things we've talked about
such as phosphates ammonia nitrates the
source of many of these these pollutants
if you want to call them pollutants are
coming off the land and it concerns me
to listen to the gentleman I think it
was Nicholas from uh
of England alluding to the points of not
having really sufficient support to give
to Farmers and moving assets from
mid-suffix a to Whitney Valley and
things like that we need to look really
closely at how we support farmers and
support the emerging agricultural
schemes not ourselves directly but
through government and how that can help
us rather than sort of voting too
heavily on what you might call tactical
Solutions in terms of looking at what's
going on this bike or that part clearly
all these things are important but a
strategic View and also that impacts on
our housing stock in terms of the
planning permissions we give and how we
manage the outflow from from houses in
the future whether you know I mean I can
only speak anecdotally but 70 of my
water is is rainwater because I live in
old house and goes down the sewer and
angling water have to deal with it so
you know there must be quite sensible
and realistic options for the future to
look incentivizing people who live in
older house or all the properties where
there isn't a diversion between sort of
rain water and and gray or dirty water
thanks
Council system thank you
um Mr John Kemp from the river star
trust expressed this this some
dissatisfaction because he didn't feel
Babel were sufficiently supporting the
bid for bathing status
um could we
reiterate our support and I personally
support it very much I don't see why we
wouldn't it would improve the ultimately
would improve the quality of the river
but get more regular testing come can we
produce a
written endorsement of in support of the
application
can I
can I answer it right I already picked
that up
and I want to ask Mark and to respond to
that because that was a very public
complaint uh Mark do you mind
responding to that thank you
uh yeah we're happy to respond to
um what Mr Kemps said during the meeting
we did write back to Mr Kemp on the 20th
of January Arthur wrote back to him
there to say that in principle we
support the application
um
made him aware that it was a complicated
issue we're aware of other stakeholders
involved we haven't heard anything from
Mr Kemp until during this meeting which
you know
we're very happy to understand more what
he wants from us
does that answer your question
yeah I think so I mean he's
he's in he felt it was a woolly answer I
think and he
I I guess he just wanted more
straightforward yes we support the
application with no prevarication
an odd ambiguous markers reassured as he
will do something about that and right
to Mr camp
um yeah
yeah oh sorry oh dear
got to put some recommendations together
can I ask Jan
um for your
advice
um so councilor any recommendations so
you're reporting back to council because
if you remember it was the motion from
Council and they asked overview and
scrutiny to look at it so any
recommendations you you make you're
taking it back to council so I was
suggesting the first instance that you
report back that you've had the meeting
and various people attended and you
might wish to take that as part of your
overview and scrutiny report that you
take to council and that's the way of
doing it but I would suggest that that's
the first recommendation is that you've
um had the meeting and you can import
that back to council
Alicia would you like to help us with
that
okay
thank you chair
sorry Terence my apologies we've had
comments regarding the water bugs could
it be a recommendation we have a large
number of properties as Council
properties residents could we make a
recommendation to councils to actually
try to supply water butts to council
properties
and therefore do I have it in reducing
food water overflow
can I just come in
the internet function
I'll say that but um and also because of
the financial implications behind that
we would have to do a properly costed
report but you could perhaps ask um
Council to look at ways of promoting the
use of water but amongst staff and their
residents and we may be able to do a a
campaign
and perhaps include the wet wipes as
well if we're looking for public action
yeah that we could do a Communications
um you know kind of thing for our
residents and counselors and staff
if you recommend
would be okay for that yeah yeah any
expenditure or sort of the day-to-day
running like the supplying of water
butts would be a cabinet function but um
you could ask Council to recommend to
the communications team uh you know sort
of about about the promotion of water
butts and not using
Alessia
made it very complex
thank you chair so
um in terms of the recommendations I
have
just take five or ten minutes just to
break to put the wording together for
members do you want us to give you that
um I'm quite happy to talk about the
points that I've got and then we can
discuss in a break in putting the actual
wording together so
um I have a generic recommendation about
um thanking the external representatives
for their attendance today and then a
recommendation about the chairs
to full Council which will happen at the
next four Council meetings in October
where um yourself and counselor cast and
will be asked to provide a report and a
verbal update on the questions that were
asked here and the outcomes
um so that full Council knows that this
meeting has taken place and then I've
made notes about recommendations about
asking the external representatives for
more information which I know is um
what's been asked for by cancer medicine
and Council of all boys and we can put
some specifics in there if you would
like
um but then I've also picked up about
um councilor Carter's comments about
water butts and as well as communication
about what can and cannot go into sewage
systems as well so um
yes that would be can I just say can you
also ask
um our Representatives about about the
um
continuation of the phosphate reducing
program in how that how they can
planning to go beyond the the original
the towns mentioned
yeah I think that's absolutely I think
that's fine we can get in contact about
that and ask for more information on
that that can also be included
potentially in
um
1.3 recommendation about going back to
them for more information so we can put
that down as a specific for you
um unless members have any other points
that they would like formulated into a
recommendation
uh yes thank you chair yes um but we'll
talk about water butts hasn't been
mentioned but I think perhaps possibly
could look at sort of um
encouraging the use of perhaps gray
water
systems for flushing toilets Etc and
sort of recycling the water it might be
something that could be put forward
to Developers
and in order to so conserve
uh fresh fresh clean water
um
I'm not sure
could can we put photos of recognition
that we
Angley water continues to avoid giving
committing itself to providing
um
clear information in regard to the
impact of development on sewage systems
and
Water Supplies
I mean I think that's what I I was
hoping for at the beginning of this
meeting that we will get a commitment
from Anglia water even though it's not
statutory
statutorily required to give that sort
of information that it would in the
interests of transparency and
and public Goodwill if you like that it
will provide that clarity about the
impact of developments on
on capacity for dealing with sewage
can I do councilman can I just ask
stay even though
she's not feasible
chair can I assist
um so obviously we can ask them to
commit to that but we have no powers
whatsoever to make to enforce that so we
can ask them if they will commit
but if they say no there's not a lot we
can do about it so you know happy for us
to ask them to commit to that I I I
realize they we can't make them no but I
think it's important for the our
residents to know that we're asking for
that information and they have a I think
they've got a responsibility to give us
that information and they're avoiding
doing so
so again we can ask them better to say
if they choose not to there's you know
it's down to them and it's it's their
public relations if you like not ours
but we haven't got any decision making
powers that we can force them into that
but we could we could ask them
absolutely I think we need to put the
ball in in their core yeah
can I can I just clarify Jan then so if
we put that in as a recommendation but
it would be the council that would have
to so we would have asked this question
so you'd asked if that was a
recommendation to council and Council
agreed that then you could ask the chair
to write of the council to write to the
anglian water authority to ask them if
they would commit to that and
essentially that would be Council of War
boys himself so
I'd be very happy to do that
I will try and free I will try and
phrase it politely
yeah thank you yeah I think we're making
good progress now and thank you very
much to the officer
um yeah if the
in in terms of
[Music]
um
what the chair might write if it was
endorsed by Council a plastic free wet
wipes I think it's the other key thing
um that we we would want to include I
think
um and one final point about the cabinet
spending money
um
part
we've heard a couple of times during the
during the day about
um what essentially called citizen
science projects and
um so I think some modest recommendation
that cabinet
um considers modest financial support to
um to such projects
because I do know that there are um
two or three going on and and other
groups that we'd quite like to etc etc
and I've heard both previously about the
riverfly approach and I've just heard
from councilor Smith about what what's
being done to look at E coli so I think
there's there's an interesting area
there which we
it would be good for the districts that
we we modestly support those
um
if we can fold it so um that that would
be my point there finally thank you
I suggest we just give the Alicia a
couple of minutes to put it all together
that's quite comprehensive
yeah sorry yeah the um yeah I think the
other thing that I was asking for a
little while ago was
um you know the the the the committee
um
sees the outcome of the fifth and final
point of the motion which was the
council Lobby MPS and off what
um with their concerns and and about
water quality
um it would be good to see that come
back
to the scrutiny committee
as to what how that went and how what
happened
if anyone can find out looking along the
back row there
John I think we've got a problem haven't
we because the Crescent committee hasn't
seen that motion
so the Motions Went to went to council
didn't they they went to councils in the
last seven minutes in 22 too but we can
we can send a link to that motion and
the minutes around that so if firm
counselors require that reference of
course that that's on the website anyway
so it is there
um I just wanted to make a point I don't
know if this affects anything I look at
Jan for this but I think 0.5 on the
motion that went in November
um only relates to Mid Suffolk I can't
see it on
the same motion went to baber council
and got voted on but I think 0.5 is only
included on the mid-suffolk version of
emotion and not baber because I can't
find it on the labor version so if we do
do anything about that it would just be
relevant to Mid or something
we're going to that that conversation
councilor Mathison will take place out
enough time now to
uh chair if I could just have five to
ten minutes to put some word in together
um with Jan and then I'll learn feedback
to the committee uh for wording and then
we can agree from there that's okay
probably read their recommendations out
so are you ready
so um Alicia will read out now the
recommendations
sorry five minute break
can I bring the meeting to order
committee
thank you
I'm going to ask Alicia to read the
recommendations that we think we've
finalized now with the help of John
thank you chair and thank you members so
I have six recommendations written up
and I hope that they cover all the
points that we've made during questions
and debate so recommendation one is just
that the joint overview and security
committee thanks anglian water the
environment agency Natural England I'm a
river store trust for their attendance
and for the answers provided
recommendation to that the chairs of
overview of scrutiny provide a report
and verbal update on the contents and
outcomes of the committee meeting at the
next full Council meetings in October
recommendation free that joint overview
and scrutiny committee requests for more
information from the external
Representatives specifically including
the phosphate reducing program and ask
that this will be fed back to the
committee by information bulletin which
should hopefully come in October should
we get all the answers to that
a recommendation for the joint overview
and security committee requests for a
wider publicity campaign for residents
staff and counselors regarding materials
that cannot be put into the sewer system
recommendation five that the joint
overview scrutiny committee requests for
cabinet to investigate the possibility
of Veronica a campaign regarding the
provision of water butts for residents
and recommendation six
um is technically a mid-suffic only
recommendation but that's right um it's
the mid-suffolk district council
received an update on their concerns
over water quality in the district from
offwa which is what was included in
point five in the mid-suffic motion
so um hopefully that covers every future
yeah which is just whether whether we
want where the cabinet wanted to
consider supporting citizen science
projects
it's coming to your minded too you could
put that request to Cabinet but it would
be the cabinet to
yeah to decide but you could put that
recommendation to them
yeah so I'm quite happy to
computer
you take that as recommendation seven if
you're happy with that
okay and councilor Carter
my apologies just a queer and Aquarion
recommendation and one
um thank you it did be not thank and
when they were here or is it necessary
to put it as a recommendation or could
we just not take it as read and do do
think
thanks for attendance
if I can assist it is it's the formal
recommend um so it'll be in the it'll be
minuteed
um so it's a formal although we thank
them informally here the committee will
vote on it and it will be a formal
record of our thanks
is that all right council person
yes thank you I'm obviously not not
being brought up very politely
more acceptable
any comments on the oh Council of all
boys yes I I may have missed it but have
I been given a job there to write to
Anglia water not not yet okay
it's all right fine
councilmanson's just clarified go
through Council before
right and everybody happy with those
recommendations can I have a proposal
please
thank you chair members that vote as
their own progress for you
sure could I have your vote
yeah my vote's full thank you
councilor Riley
said Thank You chair so that makes 10
votes for it's actually unanimous thank
you thank you
um
committee members we still have some
other parts of the agenda to follow
after that long session so just before
I'd just like to thank the officers
behind me because they've been here all
morning
thank you
for all your help
can we go to item eight
uh Jos stroke 2316 forthcoming decisions
list do members have any comments
okay
does it do I take that as a no
yeah okay I'm taking that as a no
uh item nine Jos 2317 overview on this
scrutiny Committee Action tracker do
members have any comments on that
can I
see I put that tracker together
is that working well do you think
I would say that's not really for me
tonight
because you're over committee members
you put it in place so people would know
because at one time we didn't know where
I mean for new members that was
something we weren't able to we weren't
sort of catching up with what had gone
on or what response had been so I think
I found it exceptionally helpful
so the any comments
no so thank you the overview and
scrutiny action tracker is for noting
um
item 10 Jos 2318
baber overview and scrutiny work plan
do babe remotely so this is for baber
members only do you labor members have
any comments on that
councilor Riley
at the last meeting we asked for an
update on corks Lane and some reference
please to Staffing agile working and
productivity and you have recorded in
the minutes that
um
these stresses were noted and the
conversation would take place with the
chairs and officers outside of the
meeting that was 21st of August
um
I'm surprised that these items have not
been put back into the calendar that
appear
to have been put kicked into the ground
grass since you know unless they come up
they completely disappear
and I've seen this before
with baber and I get very
irritated by all these are very valid
questions they were approved by the
meeting at the time they were accepted
by yourself and now they have gone
um can they go back please in the work
plan there's nothing like a calendar
date to focus people's minds on bringing
us the information forward
thank you madam chairman hi councilor
Riley
that's fine um just to pick up on that
point councilor Riley we
um that's my fault that that's not on
the work plan that should be under the
items to still be timetabled just to
reassure you that in the last chair's
briefing after the last committee we did
discuss the items that you proposed at
committee and we are having uh we're
still having discussions is the best way
to bring that forward and that needs to
be talked about with officers how that
is going to be presented to the
committee
um so our only after those discussions
will we be able to timetable it but I
will make sure that that goes at the
bottom of the work plans for the next
committee if not timetable already so
you shall get an update hopefully as
soon as possible
it was
I said I can assure you
item 11 Jos 2319 the mid Suffolk
overview unscrutedly work plan do you
need to Suffolk members have any
comments
I'll take that as a no then
okay
so they need some footwork planners for
number two
well members you'd be pleased to know we
the meeting has now come to an end
so I am concluding the meeting at 11
minutes past one
thank you very much for attending